meet joey a digital marketer he works as
the head of digital marketing for amazon
but how did joey get here a few years
ago joey began to see a large number of
opportunities popping up in the field of
digital marketing to begin his entry
into the field he needed to understand
what exactly digital marketing was and
what was so great about it first joey
learnt that digital marketing was a form
of marketing through which you could
advertise to people digitally digital
marketing leveraged different channels
like search engines websites social
media platforms emails and mobile
applications it would give marketers the
opportunity to interact with and
understand their audience better and to
increase the trust in their brand
digital marketing would also show
marketers advertisements to people based
on their actions and preferences on the
internet while being less expensive than
traditional forms of advertising after
understanding the main concepts of
digital marketing joey realized there
was more to digital marketing than he
initially thought there were also many
types of digital marketing types like
content marketing search engine
optimization pay-per-click social media
marketing email marketing and affiliate
marketing and once he understood those
types he set up a digital marketing
campaign for his uncle's e-commerce
website let's have a look at what he
came up with
first joey created content like blogs
videos infographics and case studies so
that he could generate audience interest
in the brand's products or services
this was content marketing
next he needed his audience to actually
see his content the first step was to
create content on specific search
keywords that were relevant to the
target audience
joey would make optimizations on the
website and have credible websites
linking back to the content and lo and
behold the website began ranking on the
first page of the search results
by continuous optimizations joey would
continue to improve the ranking and
ultimately make the website rank at the
first position this was seo or search
engine optimization and joey could do
all of this without spending a single
penny he could also drive traffic to the
website with advertisements
but for this he would have to pay a
certain fee each time the ads were
clicked you could have text ads that
show up in search engine results image
ads and video ads that show up in
websites and much more
this was possible with the help of ppc
or pay-per-click
however joey wasn't done yet to reach a
larger audience he needed to tap into
social media platforms
he would use social media platforms like
linkedin youtube facebook and instagram
to advertise the brand's content he
would use these platforms to advertise
the brand's products or services with
posts images videos and more to bring
out the brand's story and engage with
the brand's audience who spend a lot of
time on social media
like pbc he could use the platform to
advertise the brand's products or
services with text image and video ads
which needed to be paid for
that's social media marketing joey
realized that a large amount of the
audience weren't visiting the brand's
website a second time he needed to keep
them engaged nurture them to make sure
they purchased the product
for this he would send them emails that
helped them better understand the
products they visited on the website and
assist them in the buying process he
would also send emails to advertise his
products or services to potential
customers that is with email marketing
and finally although joey was able to
grow the brand's funnel he wanted more
traffic from third party websites this
could be achieved with affiliate
marketing affiliates would promote the
brand or product to their audiences for
a fee with the help of email sign ups
registrations conversions subscriptions
etc
after setting all of this up joey had
the hardest part of the process to get
through
the wait now as we wait for the results
let's take a break and look at a quiz
which one of the following forms of
marketing involves engaging and
nurturing your audience to make sure
they buy your products or services
a seo
b
ppc
c email marketing
d
affiliate marketing let us know your
answer in the comment section below for
a chance to win an amazon voucher
now let's see what happens at the end of
joey's weight although joey had worked
really hard on each of these forms of
digital marketing he only had moderate
success
that's when joey realized he had to gain
more knowledge and experience so he
decided to get certified and get ahead
in his career with the help of
simplylearn he took up simplylearn's
digital marketing certification and got
the skills and training he needed to
become an expert digital marketer and
now you know where he is
you too can do the same and grow in your
career by clicking on the top right
corner and with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of digital marketing we hope you enjoyed
this video if you did a thumbs up would
be really appreciated here's your
reminder to subscribe to our channel and
to click on the bell icon for more on
the latest technologies and trends
greetings everyone this is rob sanders
and today we're going to talk about what
is digital marketing so thanks for
joining us here at simply learn and
let's get started so today we're going
to talk about
why digital marketing is important in
today's world uh we're also going to
talk about what is digital marketing and
the types of digital marketing channels
that are out there then we're going to
talk about the customer life cycle in
digital marketing so what does it take
to get somebody from point a
to point z
through digital marketing and so those
are the topics we're going to cover so
hope you enjoy yourself while you're
learning and let's get right to it so
let's start talking about why digital
marketing is important so let's start
there on the why so
we're just a fly on the wall and we're
in an office environment we're looking
at two friends having a conversation
about digital marketing so
really if we're listening in
everybody every marketer is using
digital marketing for his or her
business now digit marketing has become
more popular than traditional marketing
that's not a surprise
so in response hey over the past few
decades digital marketing has evolved at
a rapid pace these days a lot of people
spend most their time on the internet so
what happens in the internet every 60
seconds well a lot happens every 60
seconds so according to social media
today i mean there's a lot of snaps
there's a lot of clicks there's a lot of
text there's a lot of videos watched
there's a lot of pictures being taken
there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and so the one gentleman says hey can
you also imagine a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
responds of course i can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper tv
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know with traditional
marketing reach is limited
with digital marketing reaches maximum
and what we mean by that is hey when you
print something you're printing it for x
amount of people if you're trying to
promote an event and you basically
create a thousand flyers okay you figure
it's going to a thousand people maybe
they'll share it so you're looking about
2000 people maybe just to be generous
well digital marketing we're promoting
an event we can promote it to a whole
lot of people depending on the platform
so 2000 is nothing when you're targeting
an audience on facebook or google search
traditional marketing
non-versatile and with digital marketing
very versatile so again going back to
our flyer printing an eight and a half
by eleven okay that's it you know with
with digital marketing you're running
display banners you have 468 by 60 200
by 200 250 by 250
300 by 300 i mean the list goes on on
the types of different display sizes not
to mention text ads not to mention video
or multimedia
so there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so
meaning if you're trying to get that tv
spot there might not be a spot open
until one in the morning okay well with
digital marketing there is no hours okay
you can certainly get your point out
there and have people see it
instantaneously so with traditional
marketing there's a lack of real-time
results i mean this seems like uh it's
obvious but you know digital marketing
that's one of the biggest benefits
instant real-time results instant okay
nowadays
going analytics you can look at real
time reporting okay so we could see real
time results okay traditional marketing
can be very costly i mean if you're not
only doing postcards and printing
postcards but you have to mail those
postcards so there's postage fees where
with digital marketing it's very very
very cost efficient i mean meaning you
could pick and choose who you want to
target when you want to target where you
want to target what you want to target
and if you're doing search you can put
your bidding in place you can put your
hours in place you can really control
how much you actually spend so that to
me is one of the biggest advantages to
digital marketing not only do you get
real-time results but you can control
costs and then obviously optimize based
on the amount of cost you're spending
based on those real-time results with
traditional marketing it's difficult to
reach a target audience you know with
digital marketing it's easy to reach a
target audience i mean you know i don't
want to bash traditional marketing too
much i mean if you're gonna put a tv ad
in place you know you're going to do it
on a tv show that tends to
gear more towards your target audience
but that doesn't guarantee anything here
we can simply go to facebook or twitter
or linkedin and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to target when
we want to target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing poor
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure and optimize
campaigns and what we really mean by
that is because you get instant time
results because you can control cost
because you can reach your target
audience more easily all those a result
of okay you can measure and optimize
based on what our audience is seeing and
how much they're spending to see it we
can quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally that
means that's a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now
why digital marketing has been answered
with all the benefits that
it carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so you know that
you know you want to do digital
marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just define it
digital marketing is just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device when we
talk about technology it could be an app
it could be
you know a cloud-based platform okay it
could be a piece of software okay so
a lot going on on the digital side in
terms of variations and what you can do
but that's in a nutshell what digital
marketing is you're really just using
technology to promote your product or
service so we know because of the
benefits in digital marketing you can
promote your campaign on different
platforms okay so all those benefits we
mentioned about instant real-time
results cost efficiency
optimizing campaigns you could do that
on search you could do it on social via
email on mobile apps etc so that's what
we mean by with the help of digital
devices and technology well these
digital devices and technology come in
the form of search engines and emails
and mobile apps etc so
when we want to go
and promote our product or service using
a campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and let's just go through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what i consider the king of
them all and that's seo so seo stands
for search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with seo because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic
on the search engines including google
so depending on where you're located in
the us market google ten or has a large
market share so you want your pages on
your website to be found and clicked on
organically and so that means that
somebody types in a keyword you want
that relevant page to show up first on
google so somebody can click on that
link okay and we know that millions of
people specifically in the us but
worldwide you search on a daily basis so
if you're ranking for those relevant
keywords you can imagine how much
traffic you can get okay so that's seo
okay and here's an example so you type
in online shopping well you can see the
first listing here is a paid search ad
and we're going to get to that in a
minute the second organically is amazon
okay so online shopping you think maybe
walmart you think maybe
alibaba or you're thinking probably
amazon okay so no surprise amazon's
ranking for the keyword online shopping
and so if somebody clicked on their
listing that's traffic for amazon let's
move on to search engine marketing you
know known as sem or pay per click or
cost per click or ppc or cpc or
sponsored search or google ads i mean
there's a lot of different names
synonymous with sem so search engine
marketing is really just using paid ads
on search engines just as we saw the
previous example if you want to be found
for keyword you don't have to worry
about organic if you're willing to pay
for it you just bid on that keyword and
voila you have the opportunity to appear
number one in the search results at the
top of the page for that keyword now
when somebody clicks on it you have to
pay google if it's google you're
advertising on but that's the beauty of
search engine marketing you can bid on
keywords and appear at the top of the
search results for that keyword example
here if we go back to online shopping
well
myus.com
is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happened to click on that listing then
myus.com is going to pay google
something depending on what the cost per
click is and so that could be anywhere
from one penny to a hundred dollars it
depends depends on the keyword depends
on who else is bidding on the keyword
depends on the location depends on the
time of day it depends on quality score
there's a lot of factors involved and
regarding what you pay however
the benefit of sem is visibility and
getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem such a popular choice for a lot
of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis this is an effective way to
capture leads and convert them to
customers because with email you can
personalize your emails and you can send
your emails to a segmented audience okay
so if you have emails from
females who are 35 years of age to 44
that live and say this southern part of
the united states you can segment that
and send them an email and cater that
email directly to that audience and of
course you can put some nice call to
action in there you could design it
really snazzy and you could track it
just like you can any other digital
marketing channel so email is a very
effective way to really reach a target
audience because everybody for the most
part has a functioning email account so
basically here's an example of an email
that could go out you're selling a
product
and the products promotion is about to
end well you know get that email out to
your target audience let them know hey
you have until tonight to purchase a
product and if you purchase it you're
going to get 30 off and you can put the
coupon code right in there with a nice
call to action and you can measure how
many people click on that email go to
that web page and purchase the product
using that coupon code so that's an
example of email marketing okay we have
affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is an effective way for
digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting
merchants to promote your products and
services and you're using usually a
third-party broker like commission
junction or cg.com as an example to
introduce you
the the person selling the product the
merchant with the affiliate so that
affiliate could likely be a merchant him
or himself and they can basically be a
good partner of yours by publishing your
product or service on their website so
that they can sell in order to get
commissions so it's all based on a
commission so you basically are going to
use a third-party affiliate like cj get
all these affiliates to work for you
they're going to promote your product or
service if they do sell your product or
service you're going to pay them a
commission that's more or less how it
works with affiliate marketing and you
know with affiliate marketing to me it's
a good way to you know really promote
your product or service and you can pick
and choose the affiliates or the
publishers of whom you want to work with
so here's an example
of affiliate marketing at work okay you
basically see a banner
basically you can see earn up to 12
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that and purchased for
example or joined you could pay off that
commission okay let's turn our attention
to social media marketing so social
media marketing you know i would say
it's fairly new i mean if i think about
it we're in 2019
and i remember talking about facebook
back in 2006. so you're talking about 13
14 15 years of social media it's
definitely evolved over the years and
but the concept remains the same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on pinterest or
instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're gonna promote but we
know social media can be effective
because people use social media i mean
facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you can
certainly pay to have an ad on facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your social platforms
like linkedin and twitter and facebook
and pinterest and instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising that you can
use to promote your product or service
or
you can go the organic route and
you know post content organically in
hopes of driving traffic back to your
website so with social you do have two
options here but social is interesting
because a lot of different social media
platforms out there really depends on
your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on facebook with facebook you
got mobile and desktop and you obviously
have the opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you can post
an app and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really an effective
way of really distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create content these days especially
in digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so
if you're trying a targeted audience on
say instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're going to post on there
so it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty of content marketing
really putting yourself out there
and
depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example if we look at
youtube you can see this video here
about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on youtube this is a form of
content marketing so that's content
marketing and then let's talk about
mobile marketing so content marketing
again different types but if we go now
to mobile marketing you can kind of
segue from content to mobile because the
only difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so
mobile marketing is really a strategy on
its own that helps you the company
promoting your product or service to
reach your target audience through a
mobile device and that includes tablets
and how you could do that is via
messaging you could do it via email or
you could be do it via an app okay so
you have different ways of getting your
content out there to people okay so as
an example
you can use basically sms or instant
messaging via mobile devices to promote
your product or service here's another
example
of a mobile marketing via app install
and so you can even compound that by
running a say google ad as an example
and running your google ad on say just
mobile you could do a bid adjustment
just for mobile and the goal could be
app installs okay so and you can even do
a mobile or app extension so there's
lots of ways to
really promote your app or your product
or your service via mobile marketing
okay let's talk about the customer life
cycle so
we know why we want to do digital
marketing we want to know we want we
know
what the digital marketing channels are
because we just talked about them from
seo to social to affiliate to mobile to
content to sem
okay you have a lot of different digital
marketing channels at your disposal so
now how do we go ahead and approach our
customers so that's what we're going to
talk about first so we're going to talk
about different stages of the customer
life cycle okay and the first one is the
awareness stage so we need to get our
customers aware of what we're selling or
what we're promoting okay so the
awareness stage is really
what product does your brand offer
that's a question we want to get out
there and we want to answer okay what
does a customer need your product or
excuse me why does a customer need your
product that's a question we want to
answer with digital marketing okay what
solution does your product provide okay
that's an answer to a question we want
to make sure people understand so these
are questions that we want to be able to
answer
in the form of digital marketing whether
that be mobile or content okay so
getting our information out there that
answers these essential questions and if
we could do that then somebody's going
to become aware of our product or
service okay so what product does our
brand offer why does the customer need
it and what solution does it provide
okay those are some key
questions that people tend to ask
themselves when they look at a brand
okay and when they look at a product hey
do i really need this is it gonna help
me in my life okay and who who is
selling this i mean who is this brand i
mean that's those are just things that
run through people's mind intuitively
that with the right messaging
the right channel the right type of
asset the right targeted audience you
can quickly make somebody aware of your
brand's product or service in this stage
it's help potential customers discover
your brand with the help of these
different marketing channels so
in the awareness stage you know content
is key so it's to me if we have a
website we need a blog because if
somebody does come to our blog from say
organic search seo then we can write
about that product or service via blog
and talk to our customer talk directly
to our targeted audience through that
blog and if we're not ranking
organically we can use paid search to
promote it because paid search on google
for example basically we can be right at
the top of the search results and so
somebody can actually see it when they
do a search because we know millions of
people you search on a daily basis you
could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product or service on
facebook while you're building your
community and you can use affiliate
marketing to help get the word out by
using cg.com as an example build up a
sales force of people these publishers
that are going to put your product or
service out there so to me in the
awareness stage these are the the
digital marketing channels you could
focus on now i will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display
ads mean that if you're on google's
display number you could pick and choose
your sites your demographics keywords
topics an audience you can focus on all
those different demographics to really
attract a large number of people so low
priority but it's probably also good to
focus on in the awareness stage okay so
content marketing you must create a high
quality content that people are
searching for without content it's hard
to get found
and so to me this is you know where the
blog comes in seo
take that content get it optimized okay
sem if we're not ranking organically we
can make sure we're at the top of the
paid search results or the the search
results for a particular keyword we want
to be found for and then social media
marketing using different channels
depending on the channel if we're
selling you know training like simply
learn does you know linkedin is a good
platform for us okay and then affiliate
you know basically building up a nice
network of publishers to get the word
out so these are all good channels that
we can focus in on so traffic sources
may include paid unpaid social referral
display email or direct so they they
could come in the awareness stage from
all different types of channels even
though you're focused on content i mean
you could still get traffic from mobile
or email so now that we got the word out
via all these different marketing
channels there's that consideration
stage so
you know people are aware of us now
they're considering us and that's kind
of the next stage in the process okay so
a few essential questions to address on
the consideration stage hey what
features make your product valuable to
others and how will i increase customer
engagement towards my product so those
are answers to questions you want to ask
okay what features make your product
valuable you want to basically separate
yourself from the competition basically
that's what you're trying to answer okay
so if you're promoting your product or
service on paid search and other people
are bidding on the same keyword how are
you going to stand out and then how will
i increase customer engagement towards
my product so for example if you're on
facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you gotta create
something really snazzy or really it's
gonna be attention grabbing or something
that's gonna get them to become aware of
it that's gonna separate your post from
all the other posts that are in
somebody's facebook newsfeed okay so you
really have to work hard to really
convince somebody to get their
consideration towards your product or
service so in this stage your customer
considers your product so help them
understand how your product is valuable
okay to me email works really good here
because if you have a targeted audience
this gives you the opportunity to really
answer these questions in that
particular channel email you could
support that with a promotion and
display i think display is a good option
here too because even though you know
people are trying to become aware
you know you can really hone in
and really
get them to take that next step okay
with display you can even do remarketing
so if somebody's been to your site
because they're aware of your product
they're curious you can cookie them and
remarket to them via display so display
to me is a good a good channel to use
here okay so you have email mobile
display you know sem these are all you
know good channels to use on the
consideration stage especially on search
because somebody's looking for something
and they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering a promotion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so
people are aware we're moving them
further along the funnel with email
marketing we have the opportunity to
promote the product by sending an email
directly to our audience so with this
stage plan your campaigns around
welcoming emails newsletters we can talk
about product descriptions add ratings
and reviews in the email you know we
really just want to encourage people to
purchase the product that's we're trying
to sway them over so email is a good
source to allow us to do that so with
mobile marketing we can promote the
products by sending relevant messages to
our target audience display again
retargeting because we can retarget an
audience that has been to our website
already did some research about our
brand our product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so
remember we want to encourage customers
to buy a product by creating detailed
articles about the product that always
helps and that's content okay we want to
opt for a customer testimonial okay that
helps sway people and add some guest
blogging okay we can have ambassadors
blog on our behalf or we can go out and
blog on somebody else's site okay so
blogging works both ways it's ways of of
showing yourself and telling people hey
we know you're looking for this product
here's why you want to choose us okay
moving on from the consideration to the
purchase stage so they're aware of you
they're considering you
and now we're on to the purchase stage
so the questions we want to really make
sure we address here are how are my
prices compared to my competitors and is
my brand more credible than others okay
so they're considering you but
that price point and it may not even be
the price it could be the shipping for
example the price could be good but the
shipping cost could be high so you
really want to do some due diligence and
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility that goes back to the
consideration stage and testimonials you
want to make sure you have reviews and
testimonials to really elevate what
you're trying to tell customers and that
that is hey i have a good brand i have a
good product i have a good service come
buy my stuff come buy my product and
service but you really need to support
that claim you just can't go out and say
it and so supporting that comes in the
form of what other people say and that
could be reviews that could be comments
on a social media platform it could be
you know stars on say yelp or google my
business you know make sure you do
your due diligence and make sure
you get people to you know review you or
provide testimonials because people are
going to do their due diligence before
they purchase especially if it's on
google my business or yelp or trip
advisor or whatever it is you're trying
to sell they're going to be able to see
those reviews and so do your due
diligence to get the reviews and if it
is a negative review hey that's okay you
can't please everyone you're gonna get
them that's the world we live in just
make sure you show your upper hand and
respond even to the negative as well as
the positive reviews that you get that
actually bodes well to some people
because hey it shows that i made a
mistake and you're willing to correct it
and so people actually see that that
could be the tipping point to getting
them to purchase hey look hey this brand
really cares because they're really
responding to people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their mind now with the purchase
stage according to e-consultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean providing a promo giving
them that extra incentive you know if
you don't offer promo consider it
especially on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending in an email
means that if the promo is going to end
at midnight send that email out and tell
people they have until midnight and if
they purchase today you'll even increase
it to 20 percent and email's a good
channel for that mobile can reach a lot
of people through sms okay social media
reaching people instantaneously and then
you know really with the purchase stage
it gives pro prospects an offer to help
them make that purchase so you have
plenty of channels to choose from in
fact most of these channels the only one
really that doesn't fit the
instantaneous mode is seo but you can
really focus on affiliate even though
that's a low priority here you can
really you know coordinate with your
publishers who especially those
publishers that have proven their worth
and have sold your products in the past
you get them to help promote it and
incentivize their audience so let's move
on from the purchase to the purse post
purchase stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could i sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to you know push a product on your
customer but think about how you can
complement that purchases that
purchasers or customers product and then
how to improve the customer buying
experience so
again this goes back to you know what we
just said about reviews get somebody to
offer a review and if they don't give
you
a full compliment of five stars they
only give you three and a half stars
then you know what that's great feedback
because then you can learn from that and
then the other question is will the
customer refers to others and if so why
so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchase stage so
let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know to me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you can
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice
channel you send in a nice message even
you know social media you know you can
thank your community for supporting you
on this recent campaign that you ran you
know even throwing an extra five or ten
percent on a future purchase is a thank
you and that's easily done on social
media
you know you could even post a blog you
know promoting you know the success of a
product
and then offering a promotion okay so
there's a lot of things you could be
doing here on the post purchasing stage
so to me even looking at content again
you could even you know put a survey
together you could even put a survey
together for your affiliates okay you
could even post a poll on facebook so
it's just working in with these
different channels to get some feedback
about your product and service so with
email mobile you can engage customers
with follow-up emails or customer care
content you know with mobile if you have
somebody's mobile number hey text them a
simple thank you goes a long way you
know you could say hey look if you're
satisfied let us know give us a call you
can even in the ee mobile text message
you can put a link to a survey send
emails to active subscribers give
rewards for customer feedback so if
somebody does provide feedback give an
extra 10 off you know you want to be
able to reward loyalty loyalty comes in
the form of a partnership if you're
giving somebody discounts and you have a
good product or service then they're
going to recognize that they're going to
say hey look i really like this product
and they're giving me 10 i'm going to go
ahead and purchase from these guys again
so give those discounts to those active
customers or on the affiliate network
give referral opportunities to your
customers so
if it's an affiliate publisher hey if
they're getting people to your site you
know reward them or if it's an email and
you put a four to a friend get an extra
10 off it doesn't hurt because you're
incentivizing people to help you sell
your product so with social display and
content use those banner ads or
use that content that you display on
social or the blog you're gonna write to
give customers advice in order to
maximize the value of the purchase so
again you can use these platforms to
also enhance
what they purchased so hey you just
purchased this product thank you very
much did you know you could do this this
and this with it and so that's the idea
of a post-purchase stage is to maximize
these channels to be able to answer
those essential questions about what
else could they purchase you know do
they like how do i get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
first purchase stage if a customer has
bought a pair of sports shoes for
example running shoes you can recommend
cross product sale a cross sale it could
be a pair of shorts or a water bottle or
an accessory with an exclusive discount
so that's another example what you can
do on the post purchase stage greetings
everyone this is rob sanders with simply
learn thank you for joining and today
we're going to cover digital marketing
interview questions and answers so
thanks for joining again and here's how
it's going to work so we broke out a few
questions and answers uh in different
categories a lot of you are going to be
interviewing for some jobs out there and
some of the jobs may be an seo manager
or search engine marketing manager or
email marketing manager or content
marketing manager or social media
manager so we broke up those questions
into those areas and so that's what
we're going to do we're going to start
with seo we're going to go through some
questions and i'm going to explain the
answers to those questions so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible so let's get
started we're going to start with seo
search engine optimization we're going
to go through a series of questions and
i'm going to answer those questions for
you okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you've taken or
listened to my seo courses on youtube
for seo we we talked a lot about do
follows and nofollows and and simply put
i mean do follows are just signals to
the search engines to follow the link so
there's a link on site a pointing to
site b
we're gonna basically tell google bing
and some of these other search engines
hey go ahead and follow that link now i
know files just the opposite so no
follow link doesn't allow the search
engine crawlers to follow it so if we
have a link on our site
site a pointing to
site b
we can put up a nofollow tag in there
and what that's going to do it's going
to signal to the crawlers hey don't
follow this link so
in the end if the crawlers don't follow
the link then there's not going to be
any link juice passed and so google is
not going to give you credit or give
that site credit for having a link
pointing to it or pointing to another
site or from another site and so it's
all about linking so we can control if
there's links on our site whether we
want the crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow tags so just a
reminder link jews is the reputation of
equity passed from one website to
another so if you have a link on another
website and that website is of high
quality meaning their page authority
their domain authority is high they have
a lot of content you know they're not
spammy they're really rich and they're
relevant then you may want to make sure
that the link pointing from that site to
your site is a no-follow so that way
that google can recognize the link from
that site to your site and basically
that reputation is gonna be passed on to
you okay so that's a do follow versus a
nofollow and why would we do a no follow
well it depends it really depends a lot
of social media platforms like facebook
have no follows if you have a lot of
content you may not want to be pushing
out a lot of do follows it could
actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice on to and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an seo perspective if i have a site
and i have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites i'm
going to be particular about who i allow
the search engines to follow and what
links i allow not to follow so here's an
example of what they look like so do
follow is simply just the href notice
the nofollow has the the tag appended to
it the href tag with a nofollow so if
the search engine's crawling your site
and they see that nofollow there they're
not going to follow that link and vice
versa if there's a link on another site
pointing to yours and there's a no
follow there you're not going to get
credit the search engines aren't going
to pick up that link okay so question
two what is 301 redirect and how is it
different from a 302 redirect so
301 redirects tell users and the search
engine specifically that an original
page has been moved and this is the key
word here permanently so permanently
moved we're going to explain that in a
minute so it's just moved from one page
to another and so
if we
don't have a page anymore we have a new
page let's just say you built a new
website with new urls you wanna make
sure the old page is pointing to the new
page with a 301 redirect so if a 301
redirect is permanent then a 302 is
temporary so we want the search engines
to
recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
google to
not keep that page in its search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they
may remove both pages from its index
okay but if we have something permanent
in place google may say okay this page
is permanently linking to another page
or redirecting to another page therefore
it's stable it's permanent we're going
to keep that new page in the index and
eventually remove the old page so really
something permanent is more stable in
the eyes of the search engine something
temporary may not be as stable in the
eyes of say google and if they don't see
it as stable then they may remove both
pages from the index okay so the idea is
we want to be found in google search
index and we get it sometimes pages go
away for a variety of reasons and if it
does go away just make sure you have a
new page for it and that new page is a
301 permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in seo
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the nofollow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from quite quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get more of a lion's share of
the traffic for certain keywords that
our pages are found for and if our pages
are found and getting traffic then
because we have increased rankings we're
likely going to have increased traffic
and then it's just a snowball effect so
more traffic leads to more engagement
and conversions so
the whole idea for seo is remember you
have an on-page strategy and an off-page
strategy building external links is part
of an off-page seo strategy and we want
to make sure that you know we are
relevant in the form of a link or in the
form of content on other high quality
sites being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases our
domain authority google sees this is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on youtube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with seo because videos are
found youtube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on youtube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so
make sure you go ahead and follow the
best practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty i.e low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of the title they're going to want
to probably get a sneak peek via the
description what it is so again you want
to optimize that description but make
sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on twitter facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant that's going
to grab somebody's attention and then
again we set it similar to the video
tags we want to use relevant hashtags
again just as you would with twitter and
facebook go ahead and throw some
hashtags in there that people could see
because people search via hashtagging
and then this goes about saying you did
all the work created a really great
video it's engaging it's informative you
optimized it feel free to promote your
video on other social media platforms
okay don't just stick with youtube per
se
so the benefit here is if you post it on
facebook or linkedin or whatever
platform of your choice and it gets
engagement people click on the link go
to youtube they're gonna like it and
then other people are gonna see that
engagement they're gonna see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so
promote your videos to help you with the
ranking of the video on youtube so that
does play into it so go ahead and
promote it so other people can watch it
like it comment etc and that's going to
engage other people to want to do the
same so what is mobile first indexing
this is a really important and timely
question mobile first indexing means
google's just using mobile friendly
content for indexing and ranking
websites so in other words google for
example has two bots they have the
traditional desktop bot and they have a
smartphone bot and eventually everybody
that has a website is going to be
migrated over to the smartphone bot and
so with that smartphone bot goes to your
website and starts crawling what do you
think they're looking for their
smartphone bot they're looking for
mobile friendly content if it's not
mobile friendly meaning the page isn't
designed for a smartphone browser or
let's just say the images are way too
large or you have to expand the text
just to read it you know a lot of these
these issues that somebody would have
just simply trying to read something on
a web page on their mobile device
google's not going to grab that content
so you want to make sure it's mobile
friendly so it gets indexed and so if
your website has a responsive design
google will rank your website based on
its performance on mobile devices okay
so you want to make sure that your
website is mobile friendly and if you're
in an interview and somebody asked this
question you could even take it a step
further and say look i'm going to
measure how friendly my wall my website
is for mobile devices in google search
console because google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but i
can tell you if i'm google and i'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bop and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly i'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asks you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
google search consoles
mobile usability report okay number six
list down the most important local seo
ranking factors okay so
organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or
you're looking for a coffee shop so what
you want to do is you want to create a
web page for every product and service
okay you also want to opt for your
business listings on google my business
and and there are plenty of other local
business
directories out there like yelp for
example or bing even has one so go ahead
and also make sure you have a business
listing as well but since google in the
united states has a huge market share
you want to start with google first you
want to update your nap citations on
your website maintain consistency of
your nap okay so nap is name address
phone number so
you want to make sure that that's
current and consistent so if you have a
number on your website make sure it's
the same number on google my business
okay you can embed a google map on your
website you could certainly optimize the
meta tags and content not only on your
web pages but within your google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
i mentioned yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews the hat you
have the better off you are okay so i
always say this with the uh with local
search three the main factors in showing
up for local search on say google is
obviously the key word the second is the
proximity of where that person is and
then third is the reviews so you can't
really control the proximity but you
can't control the keyword and you can
control the reviews to some degree so
work hard at getting reviews for your
business but at the same time you can
certainly work in some keywords let's
just say for your product and service
pages on your website but also you can
translate that over to google my
business okay so working in those
keywords making sure your your number
your address your name they're all
consistent and and really just spreading
your the the business out on other
directories that's really all these are
really key factors for local seo okay so
question number seven how to avoid
duplicate content getting penalized for
duplicate content so for example if you
have two different versions of a web
page you may result in a duplicate
content issue so it's just seo 101 you
never want to have two two or more pages
with the same content so what do we do
well we can avoid this in having google
penalize us by again setting up a 301
redirect remember three or ones are
permanent we can also use what they call
a canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and then the third option is opt for
preferred domain in google search
console okay so if you have multiple
names make sure you set up a primary one
and search console so those are ways to
work around it of this three i would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's gonna
sit on the page it's going to alert
google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are gonna have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell the search engines hey
this is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what are some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what i mean
by simple as possible really i mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images in other words don't have such a
large image size if you don't need
something very large don't have it okay
you want to improve server response time
what do we mean by that well your site's
sitting on a server somewhere you can
own that server or you can be renting it
out from say amazon web services or
let's just say godaddy as your register
they also have web hosting well if you
have it on say godaddy server you may be
sharing that server with other
businesses and at certain times of the
day other businesses may get a lot of
traffic and suck up a lot of bandwidth
what is that going to do that's going to
reduce the server response time for your
site and so you want to make sure you
have an idea of you know what server
your web page your website is on and you
want to be able to can have some control
over that because if your server
response is slow that's going to slow
down everything else in terms of loading
in the browser and that's not going to
be good for seo okay optimize your code
what do you mean by optimize minimify
when we see mimifying we mean get rid of
some of the redundant code if you have
css you know get rid of chop some of the
get rid of the javascript you're not
using so that's what we mean by
optimizing code reduce redirects okay
ideally you just want to have one
redirect in place you don't want to
create a daisy chain so to speak of
redirecting and redirecting after that
that's never going to bode well and it's
going to slow things down as well enable
browser caching so if you enable browser
caching basically if somebody comes back
to the page they've been on say two days
ago they're probably going to see a cash
version of that page and then off for
the content delivery network as well so
these are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just google page speed insights or even
just something generic like google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
page speed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a url when you plug
in the url google is going to analyze
the url for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see google gives a
score so we could see the score from
mobile and we could see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here i could see
some of the issues that the site may be
having in terms of page load time for
their desktop if i flip over to mobile
you know here i could see some other
issues for example
they have a server static assets with
efficient cash policy now if you're not
sure what the heck that means you can
always just click on it and you can see
some specifics here or you can just
always google it as well uh here you got
to reduce the impact of third-party code
okay so that's another thing uh reduced
javascript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
met about coding okay so sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should will tend to slow down
the site okay so you can use pagespeed
insights you can always get a glimpse of
how pages are loading simply by also
going to for example google analytics
under behavior okay you can go to site
speed and if you click on overview okay
google what google does is they do a
sampling of pages over time and in this
case based on 89 page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific pages
load your site overall simply by looking
at the site speed overview report in
google analytics to get a sense of
how quick your pages are loading now
there are certain factors that do affect
low time so obviously the way the page
is built with the code the images etc
but also the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be in the united states and have
worse network service than you do say
in
you know
ivory coast in africa okay so really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and google analytics
and get a sense of what pages do not
load fast which ones do and maybe hone
in on the pages that aren't loading fast
and address those pages first okay so
you have two tools at your disposal one
google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual target short tail and long
tail keywords okay so
remember short tail are usually one to
two keywords very broad in nature long
tail keywords or maybe three four
keywords in a query or maybe an entire
sentence those are considered long tail
keywords so usually short tail keywords
have higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower
uh volume but also lower competition but
the great thing about long tail keywords
the conversion rate will tend to be a
little bit higher than say a short tail
because it's less vague and more
specific so you can use short tail
keywords if you're trying to drive a lot
of visitors because those keywords are
going to be vague or broad in nature
long tail keywords are used for targeted
pages such as product pages and articles
so if you have a specific product with a
long name you can certainly optimize
that page for that product name again
the product name may have low volume but
if somebody types in exactly that
product name you show up the chance of
you them converting are going to be very
high so you don't have to always be that
specific of the product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail where hey maybe
you're just toned in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care a lot about the traffic you
just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are the port elements to
focus while developing a website so
we're talking in terms of seo okay so if
somebody asks me this question in an
interview what am i going to focus on
when developing a website well the
answers are right here yes we talked
about mobile mobile is so important
because a lot of websites are going to
be
indexed with google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture navigation we want to have
a simple url structure okay no overly
cumbersome the navigation should simply
be clean and neat okay if you have five
products okay maybe
you have uh in your navigation you have
something called products with all five
listed or you have all five products in
the main navigation the key is you just
wanna make it clean and neat and easy
for somebody to find the the rule of
thumb is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for google but
if complicated for the end user it's
probably going to be complicated for
google you always want to create a site
map now what is that site map a sitemap
is simply just a formatted file with to
that includes all your urls and assets
your images and your videos they're
going to be sitting on your server as
well so you want google or these these
bots to be able to find your pages and
assets and by the way you want to take
it a step further and make sure you
upload that sitemap which is sitting in
the root directory meaning domain.com
sitemap.xml okay you want to take that
sitemap and make sure you input that
sitemap location in google search
console that way google search console
has a one-way ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a website is having a robot's
text file and all a robot's text file is
it's like a lock i always say to a house
so if you lock a door in your house
nobody's gonna be able to get in that
door so that's all what robot's text
file is you're telling google and these
other bots that are coming across your
site what's locked and what's not locked
meaning what they have access to what
they don't have access to so you want to
be able to make sure you have a robot's
text file if you're trying to
not index specific pages of your website
because if you tell google don't crawl
these pages or this directory they're
not going to get crawled if they don't
get crawled they're not going to get
indexed so robot's text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and while
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website i'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it indexed so
there's a lot of reasons to have robots
text files that's the main reason
sitemap you want google to get these
pages and assets quickly okay you white
to make sure that your site architecture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
because that's what's going to keep
people on the website and engaged and
when i say content i don't necessarily
just mean words i also mean videos i
also mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if an end user finds your site
engaging google is likely going to find
your site engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asks you this question in an
interview so just to recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so the bots can easily access
and mix the content okay with a
responsive design helps to make your
website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your site's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages are on your website and where are
they located along with the videos and
images okay and then the robot's text
just instructs the search engine
crawlers to understand what pages should
not be indexed okay this is simply just
a text file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house
then give it that way okay so those are
our questions for seo again if you have
any additional questions or if there are
other questions maybe you've been asked
in an seo interview then go ahead and
add them to the comments section below
we'd love to hear from you now we're
going to turn our attention to search
engine marketing so let's turn our full
attention to search engine marketing so
we're moving away from seo and over to
pay per click and so you really have to
know your stuff here you really do uh so
a lot of the questions we're gonna ask
gonna be centered around google ads
formerly known as google ads words and
so if you're familiar with google ads
the platform then you should have no
problems whatsoever answering these
questions but that's why we're here and
that's why you're watching so
there's anything you want to add to any
of these questions as a reminder feel
free to comment under the video and so
right out of the gate question 11 what
is ad scheduling so ad scheduling is a
feature in google ads and really all it
does is allow you the advertiser to set
up certain hours or days you want your
ads to show it's as simple as that so if
you have a customer that you're running
ads for on google search and
let's just say they have a restaurant
and they're closed during certain hours
of the week then you can go into the ad
scheduler and schedule your ads to not
show when they're closed as an example
okay because if somebody calls and
they're not there to answer the phone
then it's not going to be good for the
restaurant or you the advertiser and so
that's why they have the ad scheduling
so it ensures your ads are not running
when they're performing poorly let's
just say
you know you're running a business and
you just don't get that much traffic
during the weekends well you can go in
and adjust accordingly it also there to
make sure you could serve your customers
when you do have limited client service
hours so let's just say you have a
customer service team that's going to
answer phones for a couple hours a day
well again you can schedule your ads to
show during those couple of hours a day
and then really what it comes down to is
you're making sure you can satisfy
customer demand and supply and so that
means showing your ads when you you can
best fulfill the customer's needs okay
and so that's really what it's all about
uh and that's what ad scheduling is so
take advantage of ad scheduling schedule
it according to the business hours
schedule according to how they can best
serve the customer schedule the ads when
it's performing best and don't schedule
the ads when you know you're going to
have poor performance okay so next
question what are the different ad
formats available on google ads it's a
trick question because it really does
come down to what network you're
advertising on so google has two
networks the search network and the
display network okay so on the search
network there's only one ad format and
that's text okay so google recently
changed the format of the text ads now
they're called expanded text ads so here
you can see you can have up to three
headlines and two description lines and
then you can also have ad extensions and
so you can see here underneath the ad
you have what they call site links so
shop by category in here headphones on
ear headphones those are all site links
to specific pages on the site so
text ads are available only on the
search network but they're also
available on the display network as well
then you have responsive display ads now
responsive responsive display ads are
only on google's display network okay so
here you could see
some samples of responsive display ads
and these ads adjust their size and
format depending on the space available
so again you could have text ads or you
can have display ads now display ads
again come in different sizes so you can
create ads for a variety of different
sizes for example 250 by 250 or 468 by
60. so those are some of the different
ad types there's there's a plethora of
different ad sizes you can choose
however your ads not going to show on a
website if they don't have that
particular size available so it's always
best practice to create different ads
but create ads in different sizes as
well okay and then have a backup text ad
as well just in case the site doesn't
even display a display ad for you or
serve up a display ad so you can have a
text ad as a backup okay so lots of
different ad sizes but this is the
second ad format that's responsive
display and again the responsive part is
google will automatically
show the ad that's best performing based
on a series of headlines descriptions
and images that use you provide google
and so the responsive part is hey if
this combination of headline description
and image work best meaning it has the
best click-through rate then google's
going to serve up that ad so that's why
they call it responsive so
obviously you can have just an image ad
that's not responsive again across
different ad sizes you know they could
be again 250 by 250 300 by 300 468x6
there's a number of different sizes
google can provide you that information
but the one thing to note here is that
when you do create an image ad it could
be
jpeg it could be
interactive or it could be static so
different types of image ad formats like
png for example or it could be a static
or it could be interactive so definitely
take advantage of the different
opportunities uh meaning a static ad
versus an interactive ad you may want to
have two variations of that so you could
see which one works best okay there's
also app promotion ads so these ads are
used to drive app downloads so you're
going to have to set up a campaign
accordingly okay but here you can see
this is what it looks like with a call
to action so it allows you to go ahead
and click and install that app so that's
an app promotion again if you have an
app and you want to promote it you can
use this type of ad format to align with
a campaign that's driving traffic to
download your app okay and of course you
have video ads well google owns youtube
and so if you have videos you have the
opportunity to advertise on youtube okay
so these ads can be standalone or
inserted into other streaming video
content and so to me video ads work well
with specific strategies and what's one
strategy you would use a video ad for
brand awareness or education explainer
videos and so youtube allows you the
advertiser the opportunity to get your
ad your service your product in front of
a lot of eyeballs so that's the beauty
of video ads they attract a lot of
eyeballs and
definitely help with the strategy of say
brand awareness okay another ad format
going back to the search network is
shopping ads so if you sell shoes then
you may want to think about having a
campaign for shopping so shopping ads
work with google merchants so google
merchant is another google product and
basically google merchant allows you to
manage your inventory so if you have a
hundred different types of shoes that
you're selling you can upload your
inventory to google merchant connects
and talks to google ads so basically
what you're doing you're setting up your
your campaign and google ads and
connecting your inventory from google
merchant to google ads and so the great
thing about the shopping campaign is it
puts your product front and center it
puts the price it puts any promotion
that you have and it puts the brand all
front and center so when somebody does
type in let's just say lime green
sneakers or women's sneakers and this
particular shoe shows up here the third
one from the left then somebody's gonna
see it's from the united colors of
benetton it's a woman's shoe it's on
amazon and it costs 45 so the great
thing about shopping ads is if
somebody's interested they're going to
click okay if somebody's not interested
say well you know it's a little bit more
expensive i can get something similar
another shoe on amazon for less okay
they're probably gonna click on that
particular app so again the great thing
about shopping ads put your product
front and center with any promotion the
price the brand so if somebody clicks on
it then they're probably serious buyers
okay so that's the beauty of shopping
ads it allows you to get your product
out there and on the search network it's
a cost per click so you're only paying
for the click so if somebody looks at it
but doesn't click you're not paying for
that so that's the beauty of shopping
ads and so
you can showcase your shopping ads so
these ads have an image and a
description that expand when clicked so
you can provide more information more
product and store information as well
you also have call only ads okay so call
only ads are enabled to users to connect
with your business directly using the
phone number provided okay so it allows
somebody on a mobile phone who in this
example is searching for drywall repair
well if you're in the business of
drywall repair you can have your ad show
up on mobile with the phone number and
somebody can easily click on that phone
number and just call you directly now
the way
call only ads work is you're still
getting charged for the click okay so
anytime somebody clicks and calls you're
going to get charged and you're going to
get charged just as you would if
somebody clicked on your ad so it works
the same way so it's a cost per click
again this is on search so search is
cost per click and the beauty about call
only is again
you can track the calls right in google
ads so you can have google ads track how
many people click on the number and you
can even count those calls as
conversions if they meet a certain
criteria for example the criteria is
somebody
talks to you for a minimum of 60 seconds
or one minute then google will count
that as a conversion so you can monitor
calls right in google ads and it's a
cost per click model so you can actually
see what the average cost per click is
so moving on question 13. okay what is
rlsa and how does it work well
rlsa stands for remarketing list for
search ads so if you're familiar with
remarketing on display it's similar they
just call it rlsa okay so it enables you
the advertiser to customize your ads for
people who have visited your site just
like a typical remarketing campaign okay
so you could tailor your bids and ads to
these visitors when they're searching on
google and search partner sites okay so
they're two basic strategies for using
rlsa okay so you can optimize bids for
existing keywords for visitors or you
can bid on keywords that you don't
normally bid on just for people who
recently visited your site or converted
on your site key here is you're the one
that's picking the customer you're the
one that's enabling the list if you're
trying to target people who went to your
site and didn't convert well you could
certainly optimize your bids for
existing keywords for people who went to
your site and didn't convert or you
could set up a whole new campaign for
rlsa and have a different set of
keywords with a different ad because you
know who you're talking to you're
talking to somebody who's already been
to your site they know your brand they
just didn't purchase and so this all
happens on the search network and that's
the beauty of remarketing is one you
know who your audience is because you're
the one establishing that audience and
two you're the one creating the ad so
you can talk directly to that audience
when they see your ad again in this case
on search so that's rlsa remarketing
list for search ads i recommend pretty
much any industry any client any
customer run remarketing list for search
advertising and remarketing for display
so those are two key campaigns you
should always recommend running to a
client because one again you're defining
the audience two
you're the one that's talking directly
to you it's because you know who the
audience is and three if they see the ad
and they click on it again because it's
cost per click then the chances of
converting are going to be higher
because they've already been to your
website they know who you are and so if
they click on your ad again then they
must be interested so those are all the
benefits of running an rlsa campaign
okay so number 14 what types of
audiences can be used in gdn google's
display network so a lot of different
audiences here okay so let's go through
them so you have affinity audiences so
basically affinity audiences are
basically
what are people's interests and habits
what do they have an affinity for are
there food sites travel sites shopping
sites fashion okay so that's what
affinity really relates to okay then you
have in-market custom intent life events
these are what they're researching or
planning for so again it could be travel
it can be finance etc okay you have
remarketing we just went over that with
remarketing lists for search advertising
rlsa and so when the remarketing it's an
audience that has interacted with your
website so they either came from mobile
or came from mobile and didn't convert
or female came from mobile and didn't
convert so you're the one defining the
audience there you also have a similar
audience so this is what google creates
on your behalf so these are users with a
similar interest to your site visitors
so google is monitoring the type of
traffic that's coming to your site and
based on that traffic they're going to
create a similar audience and then you
have a custom match so what you know
about your customers activities
basically so these are all the different
audience types and you can see the
different types of ads available okay so
notice the far right column video ads so
video ads are available to every one of
these audience types why because youtube
so google knows what people's interests
and habits are based on the videos they
watch they know what they're looking for
okay they
you know that they've been to your
website because they're cooking so you
can remarket them okay so video ads are
very powerful tool for any one of these
audience types so next question what are
the types of keyword matching available
in google ads okay so this is a good
question
very important if you're gonna manage a
google ads account and a campaign you
have to be aware of the different match
types you can't just go broad match
that's a sign of somebody who doesn't
know what they're doing is by bidding on
a one keyword phrase that's a short tail
keyword if you think back to seo we have
our long tail and our short tail
keywords the worst thing you could do is
bid on a keyword short tail keyword
that's broad match because what is broad
match basically broad match or keywords
that appear when a user searches any
word in the phrase now you can define
specifically
what you want your ads to appear for in
terms of keywords and when i say
specifically you can use a phrase match
so phrase match are ads that appear only
when a user searches for that exact
keyword phrase in the precise order but
with some additional words in the
beginning or at the end of the query
okay so usually these are sentences so
you could be
you know bidding on
red adidas running shoes and somebody
could type in looking for red adidas
running shoes in portland oregon okay as
an example okay so as long as red adidas
running shoes are in order in that
keyword phrase then your ad is going to
appear because it's a phrase match and
then you can get really specific by
doing an exact match so exact match are
keywords that are triggered only when
that keyword and exactly that keyword
phrase is queried so if you do an exact
match for
red adidas running shoes and somebody
types in only red adidas running shoes
then that's an exact match and your ads
going to appear so let's take a look at
these again so you got broad match okay
we got a term cheap smartphone so if
somebody types in smartphone cheap phone
smart mobile phone cheap any one of
those combinations your ads going to
appear now there's one thing you can do
for broad match and it's called broad
match modifier so you could put a plus
sign in front of the keyword for example
let's just say you really want to
emphasize the word cheap okay you're
selling really inexpensive smartphones
okay not just any smartphone but an
inexpensive smartphone so you can put a
plus sign in front of cheap and so
somebody puts in you know just
smartphone or smart mobile your ads not
going to show up because the word the
keyword query has to contain sheep so
anytime you put a plus in front of the
keyword query you're bidding on then
that means that keyword has to be part
of the keyword phrase so that's a a
broad match modifier if you will and
that prevents you from getting unwanted
impressions so we have phrase match
again blue smartphone so somebody could
type in smartphone in blue color cheap
blue smartphone notice though the second
one where it says smartphone and blue
color your ads not necessarily going to
show up because guess what blue
smartphone is the keyword query and
you're at your the query here is not in
that order so remember in order for you
to show up for phrase match the keyword
has to be in that order so i'm looking
for a blue smartphone that is less than
100 okay that could be somebody's query
blue smartphone was in that query in
that order so if somebody says looking
for a smartphone that happens to be blue
less than a hundred dollars then your ad
is not going to show up so remember it
has to be in that ex precise order one
thing i want to go back to on the phrase
match notice that there's quotes around
the keyword anytime you see quotes
around the keyword that signifies it's a
phrase match because if we look at exact
match notice there are brackets around
the keyword red shoe that signifies is
an exact match so if you put brackets
around a keyword then your signifying
signaling to google that this is an
exact match and i only want to show up
for the keyword red shoe well the only
option that will work here is the second
one red shoes okay so because that's an
exact match okay so disregard the first
and the third one because shoe and red
color is not going to work and footwear
that's red is not going to work because
this is an exact match so you're saying
i only want to show up for the keyword
red shoe and google recognizes plurals
and singulars together so somebody did
type in red shoes then your ad is going
to show up okay so moving on what are
some of the reasons as to why your ads
could have been rejected it happens to
the best of us and if you're writing ads
and they get rejected
it could be for a number of reasons so
at the end of the day you're violating
google's advertising policies so
some of the policies that could have
been violated are and just some of the
many we're just listing some here
prohibited content prohibited practices
restricted content or editorial
technical so when you look at prohibited
content i will say this you're not going
to be able to sell drugs even if you're
selling pharmaceutical products that's
considered drugs and that's going to be
prohibited or prohibited practices like
selling drugs online that's illegal in
the state so you're gonna definitely get
flagged for that okay so there are a lot
of different ways in which your ads can
be disapproved okay
but if you do see restricted content
then that means you can't advertise but
with limitations and usually those
limitations are restricted to say only
google search and not google search
partners or to a specific geography so
usually the key here is if somebody asks
this question okay there are a lot of
different reasons google's usually going
to provide the specific or the reason
why it got disapproved and they're
usually going to include a link that you
can refer to okay so at least google
does that much they're not going to
leave you in the dark
ads just been disapproved they're going
to tell you why and include a link that
you can go to figure out how you can
best resolve the disapproved ad so what
are the different kinds of bidding
available in google ads so we already
covered part of this earlier on so
remember google search network is only
cost per click cpc when we talk about
google's display network you have three
options cost per click cost per view and
cost per impression and cpm is cost per
1000 impressions so you're paying per
1000 impressions impression is when
somebody actually sees your ad cost per
view
is actually somebody looking at your ad
for at least 30 seconds or the entirety
of the ad so if the ad video ad only
runs 15 seconds and somebody watched the
entirety then you're going to pay per
cost per view so if your video is two
minutes long and somebody watched 30
seconds you're gonna pay cost per view
okay so again let's go through these
cost per click it just enables you to
set up a maximum price on the cost of
somebody clicking on your advertisement
you only pay when somebody clicks on
your ad okay cost per view again this is
the default method to set the price
you'll pay for your video ads okay you
only pay when a viewer watches your
video advertisement for at least 30
seconds and then cost per 1000
impressions so this is the amount you
pay each time your ad is displayed in
the search network and you pay for
impressions that are generated for your
ad and you're paying for every 1000
impressions so the m is actually the
normal uh roman numeral for 1000 so
that's where the m part comes in so
you're paying for 1 000 impressions so
every 1 000 eyeballs you're gonna pay a
price and so cost per impression is good
for brand awareness if you're trying to
generate a lot of eyeballs onto your
brand then you'd want to go with a cpm
model okay so question 18 what are some
automatic bidding strategies so let's
define automatic bidding strategy
automatic bidding allows google take
over okay not you google's taking over
and they're the ones setting the bid
amounts automatically and it's gonna be
based on criteria and some of that
criteria is going to be centered around
conversions so if google bids on your
behalf automatically basically what
they're doing is they're collecting data
on the behavior of your ads and so if
your ad is likely to get the click or
conversion then google is going to set
the bid amount so you can win that
auction in order to get the click or the
conversion so
there are different types of bidding
strategies but remember you have to
align a bidding strategy with the
strategy of the campaign so for example
if your goal of the campaign is to
increase site visitors you just want
people to click on your ad and go to
your website then you're going to have
an automated bidding strategy of
maximize clicks that aligns with your
campaign strategy so this strategy
automatically sets your bids to help to
get as many clicks as possible within
your budget so google is going to do its
best based on historical performance of
the campaign to generate traffic to your
site that's the goal that's the biz
strategy okay let's take a look at some
others so
hey the goal of our strategy campaign is
to increase visibility so that's an easy
one remember cost per impressions hey we
want to maximize how many people look at
our ads okay so target impression share
so this bidding strategy allows your
bids to show at the top of the page okay
so you're getting the impression so
people are able to look at your ad okay
so you're telling google hey i want to
be shown at least 50 of the time when
somebody types in a keyword that i'm
bidding on so they're going to make sure
that they meet your target impression
share 50
so they're gonna set your bids
automatically to make sure your ad shows
at the top of the page so it's seen at
least 50 of the time that's the goal of
the campaign that's the bidding strategy
goal we set up a campaign to drive
conversions so there are a couple of
bidding strategies against conversions
so target cpa so this strategy sets a
search or display bid to get as many
conversions as possible but there's a
caveat here cost per acquisition is what
cpa stands for so we're trying to get as
many conversions as possible but at a
certain cost for example if i'm selling
t-shirts for ten dollars do i want to
pay twenty dollars cpa for every sale do
i wanna pay google twenty dollars no i'd
be losing money i'd be out of business
okay so if i'm selling t-shirts for ten
dollars on my website i'm probably gonna
put the cpa about two dollars or three
dollars again depending on my cost of
goods so if i factor in my cost of goods
i'm trying to make a profit then i'm
going to tell google look i'm trying to
get some sales but i don't want to lose
money getting the sale so you're going
to put in a threshold and that threshold
is your target cpa and so google is
going to automatically bid and win the
auction for keywords when they feel
those keywords can get you a target cpa
that you put in for example two dollars
okay so the goal of our campaign is to
meet a target return on ad spend meaning
return on advertising spend meaning
we're getting more revenue than we're
spending that ratio needs to be positive
so google's gonna help us again adjust
our bids to make sure that our return on
advertising spend meets our criteria so
we could put a roas as 100 200 etc and
google's going to adjust our bids
accordingly based on the keyword that
they think will meet that criteria of a
hundred percent or 200 percent so that's
target return on advertising spend and
that's there to see if google can help
you generate a profit so we have another
campaign set up we're trying to get more
conversions we have a budget we want to
spend the budget but we don't we want to
get conversions so this is a gimme the
bidding strategy here would be maximize
conversions so this strategy sets bids
like all the others it automatically is
going to adjust your bid that is google
it's going to adjust the bid to help you
win the auction based on historical
performance so if a keyword and
historically has performed in terms of
conversions you better believe google is
going to try and win the auction on your
behalf to get the click to get that
conversion and that's maximize
conversions okay moving on question 19
and this is probably the most important
question
that you're going to get if an interview
asks you this question this is what
google ads is all about quality score so
what is quality score so simply put
quality score is a score between 1 and
10. given every keyword you've been on
and basically between one and ten and
space google's giving you the score the
quality score of that keyword and so how
does google come up with that score
between one and ten well there's three
main factors here one is expected
click-through rate the second is ad
relevance and the third is landing page
experience so obviously a higher quality
score the better off you are okay a low
quality score it's not going to bode
well for you and so if you have a low
quality score google actually will tell
you
which of these three components you're
not scoring very well on so you're
either going to get a below average
average or above average for each of
these three components that make up
quality score and i will tell you this
if i were to divide them up into thirds
click through rate expected
click-through rate is more important
than the other two so that's about
two-thirds of quality score an expected
click-through rate is basically google
saying look other advertisers have bid
on this keyword and their click-through
rate has been historically around say
for example three percent so if you
can't get three percent then your
quality score is going to suffer ad
relevance is simply does the ad or is
the ad relevant to the keyword you're
bidding on likewise for the landing page
but the landing page experience a little
bit more subjective because the landing
page has to load well
fast no pop-ups no a lot of external
links nothing spammy no ads being served
up so a lot of factors and landing page
experience google wants to make sure
somebody clicks on your ad that they're
going to have a good experience when
they land on that page and so
quality score is so key here it is very
key because if you don't have a good
quality score the repercussion means
you're going to have to bid higher
because quality score times bid
equals ad rank so for every auction
whoever has the highest ad rank is going
to be at the top of google search
results so if you have a low quality
score let's just say one and you're
bidding four dollars on that keyword
then your ad rank is four one times four
is four so you gotta keep that in mind
because other advertisers could have a
higher ad rank or better quality scores
for that keyword so again expected
click-through rate this just shows how
likely it is that your ads will get
clicked when shown for a particular
keyword google expects a certain number
here you should always try to achieve
the highest click-through rate possible
and click-through rate is simply how
many times your ad was seen versus how
many times it was clicked that's all
click-through rate is clicks divided by
impressions so you should always try to
achieve the highest click-through rate
possible that will avoid getting a low
quality score add relevance so add
relevance simply means how relevant is
your keyword to the ad okay so if you're
bidding on reddit adidas running shoes
then make sure your ad discusses and
mentions multiple times naturally red
adidas running shoes okay and remember
with those text ads you have three
headlines you have two description lines
of up to 90 characters you have side
extensions okay you have path one and
path two that meaning you can add
additional keywords to the end of a url
so you have lots of opportunities to
make sure the ad is relevant to the
keyword and then landing page experience
again this is a little subjective but
hey google is going to use landing page
experience to estimate how relevant and
useful your website's landing page will
be to people who not only click on your
web but land on that page so does that
page load fast does it have any
unnecessary pop-ups does it does it have
some quirky external links that looks
spammy okay you got to take all these
things into consideration and think
about the end user here then last
question for search engine marketing so
what are the hallmarks of a good ppc
landing page so going back to landing
page experience this is a good segue so
you always want to make sure you have an
attractive and powerful headline on the
page remember it's got to be a nice flow
you're bidding on a keyword somebody
types in the keyword they see your
attractive ad they click on that
attractive ad which has the keyword in
it they click on the ad to go to landing
page they want to be able to see
something very similar to what they
typed in the ad they saw they want to be
able to see it seamlessly on the landing
page and so that attractive and powerful
headline should include that keyword
should also have persuasive copy that
can convince prospects to convert to me
bullet points always work here simple
bullet points easy to read easy to
understand easy to just convey the
positives about what you're trying to
sell or convert have engaging media like
videos videos always help because
they're interactive it keeps people
engaged longer or have some really good
images don't just go stock photography
you know compliment the video with some
images and then your landing pages
should have enough white space to draw
attention to specific elements on the
page and meaning don't cram the page
together because remember users are also
coming to these pages via mobile so you
got to take that in consideration as
well so cramming your pages full of
content videos and images is probably
not going to bode well so make sure
there's breathing room for people to
read understand and react and those are
hallmarks of a good ppc landing page
some other factors here adding trust
indicators like
some statistical evidence meaning how
many people downloaded your app you can
always have testimonials you know
third-party sales of approval like
better business bureau you know privacy
policy links help okay so you want to
add some things in there that's gonna
you know give you credibility having a
properly designed lead capture form to
collect visitors information is always
helpful if you're trying to get that
conversion then have a lead form make it
simple don't have a lead form with 20
forms or fields you know have a simple
name email address make the phone number
optional and have one feel that they can
type in specific information and then
last but certainly not least have a good
call to action so make sure that call to
action aligns with what you're trying to
do again selling those red adidas
running shoes if they're on sale then
you know make sure the call to action
aligns with that sale you can always say
you have 20 off for the next two days or
you know 10 off if you purchase today so
have some good strong call to action
okay let's turn our attention to email
marketing so email marketing's
traditional digital marketing channel
it's been around a while and you're
going to be asked some questions that
are going to encompass a lot of things
related to the delivery of emails uh we
all check emails on a daily basis we all
receive them sometimes we receive emails
unsolicited sometimes we sign up to
receive emails sometimes we receive
emails from friends sometimes we receive
emails where we're working or previously
have worked so most people have an
understanding of email however as a
marketer there's a little bit of a
different twist to it so we have to
understand the intricacies of how email
marketing works so you're going to be
asked some questions and really the
first question here is what's the
difference between a hard and a soft
balanced email so if you're a digital
marketer you're in charge of sending out
lots of emails let's just say thousands
or i mean it could be in the hundreds of
thousands of emails you're going to get
some bounces and so you really want to
know the difference between a hard and a
soft bounce so a soft bounce just means
that the email message reached the
recipient's mail server but bounce back
is undelivered so think of it as
delivering actual mail to a post office
so it actually reached the post office
but it bounced back because
maybe the
you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to handle that
email now hard balance is an email that
that is rejected because it's an email
when it happens when the email has been
permanently rejected so for example
maybe the the the account is no longer
valid and so let's look at some reasons
again as to why a soft bounce would
happen so for example the inbox is full
or
the recipient server's down so reach the
post office but there was a problem
actually getting it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different let's
just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay a spam or something to that
effect so the email server is going to
identify that and it's not even going to
reach the recipient so
a lot of different ways in which an
email may not make its recipient so not
the most important thing to know here i
just the important thing to know is
listen when you send out an email you
got to pay attention to how many get
bounced back and so next question here
what would you do to improve the
click-through rate of your email so
click-through rate is simply how many
people have seen your email and how many
people actually clicked on a link in the
email so if a hundred people saw your
email but only one person clicked then
it would be a one percent click-through
rate so we want to be able to make sure
we have a high click-through rate so
remember emails are going to people who
likely signed up to receive your email
and even if they are expecting an email
or they're not expecting an email you
still want to follow some of these best
practices here one is to create a
compelling subject line so you want to
make the subject line something that
people are going to notice take note of
or take an interest in and say hey
what's this all about that's pretty
interesting and open the email so use
preview text effectively obviously you
want to make your email mobile friendly
because most people look at their emails
on their mobile phones you want to
create engaging content okay so the
content that's in the email obviously is
going to have some links so put some
strong call to action in there and
that's one of the bullet points down
below place the cta where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to a
hundred people okay maybe you want to
divide it up boys or girls maybe older
or young maybe you know living in one
part of the country versus another part
of the country i mean those are examples
of segments so break up the email don't
send it to one mass email to everyone
that way you can personalize the email
if an email is personalized the chances
of somebody clicking on it are going to
be greater and then a b test your emails
and when we say a b test you know you
can send out the same email twice except
one segment's going to say get one
version of the email the other segment
is going to get another version of email
and what are the different versions
maybe the subject line so the subject
line is different on version a versus
version b or maybe the call to action is
different so you always want to
send out different versions of the same
email to a different segmented audience
that way you can actually see which
segment or which version got the most
clicks okay so next question here is how
to inform your customers about company
news and establish a relationship with
your target audience okay so again how
do you inform your customers about
what's going on in the company and how
you're going to establish a relationship
with that audience who's receiving that
email well newsletters are always the
best answer here so somebody signs up
for your email let's just say they
actually purchase a product from you
newsletters are great way to reach out
to that audience to get them to stay up
to date with the latest product or an
improved version of the product they
purchased and then that way they can
come back and continue to purchase the
product so newsletters are great way to
reach out to
your audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking verbally
you're talking to them via email so you
send out that email campaign maybe it's
once a month hey we noticed you bought
this product we have similar products
just like the one you bought or hey you
know if it's a software maybe hey we've
got upcoming updates to our software
make sure you go to the website and get
the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more update upgrade
whatever so newsletters the way to go so
again some basic tips here you want to
create your newsletter with 90
educational and 10 percent promotional
so remember you're sending out a
newsletter to people who likely signed
up so you're educating them about your
products always create interesting
subject lines you want whether they know
you or not you want to create the
subject line so somebody's going to
click on it so make sure you design your
emails appropriately okay so if you know
you're sending let's just say baby
products to mothers or expected mothers
in fact this is a real life example
because i used to work at a gap and
baby gap was you know one of the emails
groups i was responsible for so we
created an email template with softer
colors your yellows your your light blue
you know it wasn't black or dark red or
anything that's going to be you know
heavy we knew who our audience was and
we designed the template accordingly and
of course using compelling images so for
selling baby products you're going to
put baby product images in there i mean
it's common sense but you'd be surprised
you got to pick and choose your images
carefully especially if you're sending
to an international audience because
images can be misconstrued and just like
we mentioned with the click-through rate
you always want to
have a clear cta always make sure you
have a cta in a visible position because
most people are going to look at that
email in a mobile phone okay and then
always make sure you include your
contact information in the newsletter so
somebody knows where to find you how to
contact you where to go maybe they have
a product they want to return okay so
you always want to put that contact
information normally it's at the bottom
of the email but these are all best
practices so
here's some examples okay we got you
know check out the latest cosmetics from
our new collections notice the image and
notice the call to action so you can see
trendy collections you know we got some
other products you may want to buy okay
five important skincare products that
everyone should have view more so you
always want to have that call to action
in a very visible place so define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
going to have to know what these are so
we already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices for improving the
click-through rate so for those of you
that remember what that is go ahead and
put that in the comment section below
just a little pop quiz for you if
anybody remembers click-through rate but
let's take a look at open rate so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who actually open
the email so if you send it to
x amount of people how many people
opened it that would be the open rate so
how many people open it but you're gonna
take out the people who balanced it
whether it's a soft bounce or hard
bounce okay you're not going to count
those people so
if you had let's just say
20 people open the email and you sent it
to a hundred people then and you had
nobody balanced then it would be a 20
open rate okay click-through rate again
pop quiz it's just how many people
actually clicked on any of the links in
your email and that's just divided by
the number of of the emails you've sent
out a response rate okay so response
rate is the percentage of the total
recipients who clicked on the link of
your email campaign and actually
completed an action so what is that
action well it could be downloading
something watching something purchasing
something so that's the response rate
similar to conversion rate if you're
working in a digital marketing channel
and you're driving traffic to the site
you want that traffic to do something
well it's no different in email
marketing we want people to take action
we're just going to divide that by the
number of emails delivered and that
gives you your response rate so let's
just say you did send in 100 emails you
did get 20
open it and of this 20 let's just say
one person went on to purchase well
you'd have a one percent response rate
and then a ford rate is simply the
forward rate refers to the rate at which
your subscribers share your email uh
with others friends family etc and you
may have that as a call to action in
your email in fact that's a best
practice so it's just the number of
clicks on a share divided by the total
number of delivered emails and you're
going to multiply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at question 25 here
how do we capture inactive customers
what you want to do here is re-engage
subscribers with gamification opt for
subject lines like we have been missing
you or did we do something wrong you
want to run a poll or a competition and
re-engage their subscribers again trying
to get people involved these first three
are all about getting people involved so
personalize your emails talk to that
person as if hey look i haven't heard
from you in a while how about coming
back and taking a look at our new
products just as you would a friend say
design always matters especially knowing
that you're talking to customers who
haven't been active okay this is a
segmented audience somebody who's
inactive so you want to have the right
design the right message the right
subject line that fits with that
customer's inactivity so you want to try
and do everything you can to get that
customer back and then you want to
follow a consistent schedule okay so
ideally when you schedule an email you
want to schedule the best time so you
have to know your audience obviously and
then you can always ask for feedback why
are they inactive why haven't they
purchased in a while so the whole idea
here
from gamification like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to
adding polls to really personalizing it
these are all things that you can do to
get your customers back so 26 so what
are the different ways to segment buy a
persona so again when we talk about
segmentation we're talking about taking
a smaller piece the entire pie so what's
one way to break up that pie if you will
by geography okay so with geography you
could target your audience based on that
area and it could not necessarily have
to be by a part of the country it could
be all the way down to the province the
state the actual city the county okay if
you live in a small village okay all the
way up to the continent okay so think
about how you would break out the
segment by geography now obviously if
you break it out let's just say the
united states to the southern part well
the southern part you know in the winter
in the united states the southern part
is not going to be as cold to say the
northern part so that should tell you
hey we're going to send an
email in the winter we're not going to
use snow and blizzards as our theme
we're going to use probably a little bit
of sun so breaking it out by geography
helps you understand where your audience
lives you also have demographic
segmentation this is simply just age
education income gender you know where
people work okay nationality anything
that's going to identify that user so
this is the best way to segment if you
know who your audience is by income or
gender i mean you're talking to a group
of like-minded people if they're all the
same age from the same generation then
you could talk to them appropriately and
you're not going to talk to an older
person the same way you would a younger
person so think about demographic
segmentation because it really helps you
hone in on your messaging and you have
behavioral segmentation so behavioral is
based on your audience's behavior have
they purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long did they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior and decide how you want
to break out your emails by behavior and
this is a really good way if you're not
even sure who your audience is or where
they live and how old they are you could
certainly break out your audience by
behavior because you know who these
people are based on what they've done
previously because you're going to track
that information with analytics so you
know one way is obviously if somebody's
purchased that's a good way to segment
because you know these people believe in
you believe in your business believe in
your product so the way you can message
to somebody who's purchased before is
going to be different than somebody you
don't even know who they are if they
purchased or not okay so behavioral
segmentation to me is one of the easiest
things the easiest ways to segment your
email list 27 how would you drive repeat
customers through email marketing for
the below scenario okay so this is a pop
quiz if you will again for those of you
that got click the rate correctly kudos
let's see if you can go two for two here
okay so if you know the answer to this
go ahead and comment below but let's
just say give a few examples of subject
lines to drive engagement for audiences
based on the following if i had an
audience between 20 and 30 years old
that were female and the product were
sandals okay what were some of your
subject lines be so i'm gonna give you a
minute to think about that and put it in
the comment section below now remember
this is an interview based question so
you're gonna have to think on the spot
i'm gonna give you a minute but if
somebody presented that to you in an
interview you need to be able to you
know react fairly quickly and come up
with some really attractive subject
lines here okay so here you go here's
another one uh so give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for 20
to 30 females for footwear so you got
friday sale coming up buy branded
sandals at the lowest price okay so i
like this one because it's got a strong
call to action buy here you go this is
even better because 50 off on branded
sandals and free shipping i mean who
can't beat free anything including
shipping and if it's 50 off i mean these
are key things you're putting the
promotion and percentage off all in the
subject line so that's really going to
grab somebody's attention we can see for
women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurts so those are all
good subject lines they all tend to work
because they all have an element of a
best practice in there so
here you got you know the friday sale
coming up is just giving people notice
okay the stronger call to action on the
buy you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know using an emoji
to really just drive home the point so
all these subject lines will work and
hey at the end of the day remember you
want to test your subject lines okay
moving on to the next question speaking
of testing what does a be tested and
give some examples of a b testing okay
so we talked a little bit about a b
testing with subject lines so simply a b
testing when it comes to email marketing
it's just a method to analyze which of
the two email campaign strategies is
most effective all you know you're going
to do it based on open rate you can do
it by saying click rate you can do it
based on response rate and remember
you're putting one version of the email
against another version whether that be
the subject line whether it be the
content call to action whatever so
that's ideally what you're trying to do
you're trying to figure out what works
for your audience that's the end goal
for email for a b testing and email
marketing what's going to work and i
would highly suggest you should always
do a b testing for subject lines always
so some of the variables that you can
test again subject lines okay you always
want to try if you got a promotion hey
will the percentage off work likely it
will but let's test it up against
something else like you know a generic
word like discounts you can always test
the design you can always test the
personalization the preview text you
could try out images call to actions
exclusive offers what particular offer
is gonna work okay so if you're testing
offers then obviously that's going to be
response rate if you're testing ctas and
that's going to be click-through rate if
you're testing subject lines that's
going to be open rate so you want to be
able to test different elements of the
email to figure out what works and what
doesn't work okay so
how to prevent email from getting into
spam so if you're an email marketer this
is your worst nightmare you don't want
your emails to get spammed so that
doesn't bode well for you so most email
marketing platforms like mailchimp or
constant contact measure spam so some of
the important ways to prevent this is
hey improve your open rate remember
going back to the first question second
question you want to have really good
subject lines here okay and you want to
segment your audience so if you're if
you know who you're talking to and you
have a cool subject line that's going to
get somebody to react and open then
that's going to prevent somebody from
spamming your email okay you can always
customize your from to make it look like
it's coming from in this case rob
sanders check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so give people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option to unsubscribe they could
just report you as spam make sure your
emails work on different devices okay
you want to optimize your images for
email make sure they're not big and they
don't fit on a mobile device okay prefer
more text and fewer images and then
avoid grammatical issues you want to
come across as professional you don't
want somebody looking at your email like
who sent this why you send it to me i
don't want to hear from you again i'm
going to spam you you want to prevent
that and that means a professional
looking email professional content with
a really good subject line and some
imagery to go along with that hey you
may just get somebody to open that email
and get them to convert that's the idea
behind it so these are ways to prevent
somebody from actually spamming you and
then what are the best practices for
email subject lines so the subject line
is the most probably the most important
element in email marketing so we talked
about that little pop quiz with the
sandals targeting 20 to 30 year old
women you know to me i like the subject
line with the 50 off so that was a
number in the subject line so people can
actually see hey wow i get a whole 50
percent that works better than just a
discount okay remember one of those
subject lines had an emoji so don't be
afraid to include emojis in there for
example when i send out emails using you
know during the spring you might want to
use flowers perhaps to signify hey it's
spring winter's over so personalize the
subject lines remember that goes with
segmenting so if you know who your
audience is your your subject lines can
be a little bit more personal okay so
opt for title case subject lines okay so
instead of making it grammatical for
example okay you want to keep your
subject lines short and to the point
remember you want to say something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention if you make it long and drawn
out and boring then people aren't going
to open it develop a sense of urgency
like hey we got 50 off through friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's thursday i
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent any mistakes but also give you
feedback on the imagery the design etc
okay so these are all best practices for
good subject lines okay so subject line
is the most important element for email
marketing so just keep these in mind
subject lines and having good subject
lines is the way to get people to open
it and from there that's half the battle
somebody can open the email then you've
just set yourself up for better
performance okay let's turn our
attention from email marketing to social
media marketing one of the interesting
channels hot trend channel a lot of
people want to get into social media
marketing a lot of jobs available but
you have to know what you're doing so
let's get into it uh and here's some
questions you might be
asked in an interview related to social
media marketing social media marketing
is very interactive
a lot of people posting information
whether it be a tweet a post
sharing liking engaging commenting i
mean a lot of things going on in social
media so some of it is going to probably
be good most of it's probably going to
be good but every once in a while you're
going to get a negative comment so
you're probably going to be asked this
question how do you respond to negative
comments well very simple you got to be
quick to acknowledge okay don't sit on
it you know don't waste time
him and hot how you're gonna respond you
really have to acknowledge the comment
and start the process of constructive
engagement to turn the negative
experience into a positive one so let me
just expand on that for just a second we
know you like your brand we know you
like your product we know you're very
proud we get that i'm proud i like to
defend sometimes my beliefs however you
gotta put that aside when it comes to
social media why because everybody is
watching you and everybody can read what
you write so you the spotlight is on you
not necessarily the consumer the
customer who wrote the negative comment
so you really have to be cognizant here
and conscientious of what you post in
response so be quick but be constructive
because you want to turn that negative
into a positive that's really what it's
starting with so how do you do that well
how do you be constructive well see it
from the customer's point of view take
off your ownership hat if you will your
manager hat and put on the customer's
hat always look at something from
somebody else's perspective try to
understand why that person wrote that
negative comment and ask yourself how
you can make it right so if you're the
customer and you are your customer when
you go to the store and buy food you're
the customer when you go to the store
and buy clothes when you buy a car
you're the customer so ask yourself what
you can do to make it right why you're
thinking in the customer's perspective
or looking through their eyes if you
will to me it's it's not an easy thing
to do but it's something you have to do
okay so always look at it from a
customer's point of view and then take
it out of the spotlight so
really because everybody's looking at
you waiting to see how you respond and
remember this customer that wrote the
negative comment can certainly share
your comments to the world so you got to
be really really careful i mean how many
times have we seen on youtube you know
poor customer experience going viral on
on via video so you just got to really
be careful here so take it out of the
spotlight so offer to resolve the
customer's problems in an appropriate
form offer up your phone number an email
give them a link to a feedback form or
get their email or phone number and call
them these are the best ways to really
bend this into a more positive
experience for the customer i mean at
the end of the day could become
something really small and silly but
don't make a mountain out of a mall hill
if it is something small and silly how
you respond could make it into more than
what it really is so be quick be
constructive look at it from the
customer's point of view and offer as
much support as you possibly can okay
that's how you want to respond if
somebody asks that question in an
interview some other comments here so
keep track although the issue might be
solved it doesn't necessarily mean the
commenter has gone away so follow up
with them if you resolved it follow up
with them a month later hey surprise
them two months later give them a
discount okay you'd be surprised
positivity goes a long way and it's
always nice when somebody actually
follows up with you after the fact just
to make sure they want to know that
you're taken care of and then don't feed
the social media trolls okay so ignoring
trolls across social media will make
sure they don't enjoy the notoriety it
brings so don't even allow the
negativity to feed itself so that's why
you really have to stay quick
constructive you know look at it from a
customer's point of view and just turn
this whole experience into a positive
experience it's an opportunity for you
to hone your skills let's move on to
another question so somebody may ask you
to give an example of a successful
social media campaign okay so if you're
going in to interview for social media
manager job you probably want to do your
homework in advance look at what other
people have done so here's a good
example spotify you can see the spotify
ad here with ed sharon spotify mind the
search and playlist data of its user
base to develop a thematic branded ad
experience on billboards in 18 markets
around the world first of all let's just
take this and break it down ed sharon's
popular you can see here be as loving as
the person who put 48 ed sharon songs on
their i love ginger's playlist so
messaging is everything okay and then
you can see what spotify did they mine
the search and playlist data of its user
base okay so they try to understand
their audience going back to email you
gotta understand your audience okay then
they used that to develop a branded
experience on different markets around
the world so they took an audience and
they really marketed this around the
world okay to something that was really
hot and trendy i'd love to see how this
thing actually performed my guess is it
did perform fairly well because when
you're spotify you're gonna pick
something hot and trendy to get people
to react and so to me this seems like
just on the surface a very successful
social media campaign here's some other
things uh you could see these ads were
featured on the sides of buildings
subway platforms along busy streets so
it wasn't just digital per se i mean
they really went full bore on the
billboards and those billboards were
everywhere on the sides of buildings
again in 18 different markets so you can
see it wasn't just necessarily ed
sheeran per se but you know they had
some good messaging and gr enjoy green
light at every red light that's pretty
cool i guess if you're stuck in traffic
in the middle of a city less fake news
more fake magic so they really took and
honed in the type of music put some good
messaging behind it and really put it
out there so it doesn't always
necessarily have to you know necessarily
be digital per se but they what they did
was they did post this on the sides of
buildings and subway platforms and
throughout different city streets for
maximum visibility for their fans to
upload to their social media okay so do
your homework okay and on this next
question you certainly want to do your
homework so if you're a social media
manager you're probably going to be
involved in some facebook advertising
okay so this is a basic straight up
question what are some of the different
types of ads you can run on facebook you
know you can do single image ads most of
us have probably seen that you can do
multi-product lead ads slideshows
collection ads video ads i mean you got
all sorts of a variety of different ad
formats here okay so let's take a look
at these ad formats single image again
most of us have seen it okay it's just
simply a single image that you know how
allows you to put some text at the top a
link at the bottom or linked to your
website or your facebook page and a
strong call to action okay so facebook
has that built into their ad platform
okay so the ad images need to be 1200 by
628 pixels it's a pretty nice size image
multi-product ads so multi-product ads
are
represented in carousel form so
basically it allows you the end user to
view the range of products just by
scrolling and notice each one of these
products has a call to action so here
you can see simply learn offering up all
the different courses they have to offer
so if you have a customer that has
multiple products this is probably the
way you want to go so video ads are very
popular on facebook so video ads usually
range from a few seconds all the way up
to 120 minutes and again video is very
engaging if you have video use the video
okay because they receive about 10 to 30
more views than other forms of ads okay
who doesn't like engaging with video
pretty simple you have lead ads so lead
ads allow you to obtain user details
like name phone number email right in
facebook's environment so it allows you
to collect information right then and
there so lead ads can be effective if
you're trying to get people to sign up
for something slideshow so we looked at
those multi-product ads where you had
the carousel slideshow simply just
allows you to rotate different creative
with nice imagery so the key here is
nice imagery okay you want to put your
best foot forward choose the right
imagery just like going back to the
email marketing you know going back to
pay-per-click you want to use some
effective ads here and images in the ads
okay you also have collection ads that's
another option on facebook so collection
x ads combine video slideshow or product
images taken from your product catalog
so i would recommend this for users who
want to advertise several other products
at once okay again simply learn has a
lot of different courses a lot of
different thousands of courses so you
know collection ads works for them you
can see here you got social media
certification you got ppc certification
seo certification okay these are all
different certification courses you
could take it simply learn and they want
to go ahead and promote all those
courses together so lo and behold
collection ads offers the best option
here so pay attention those different ad
formats on facebook okay next question
how can you use the holiday season for
social media marketing well this is a
nice segue from the previous question
because you know you have on facebook
all these different ad types so you
could change your ad placements to ones
lesser used by other advertisements you
can also set up clear simple and
compelling offers for your users the
holiday season you're likely going to
have some sales and again make sure your
images have under 20 of text okay that's
a standard across the board but again
you want to have nice imagery so think
about all those different ad formats on
facebook think about the holiday season
and how you can accentuate your ads here
okay i'm thinking video here i'm
thinking a promotion in the video i'm
thinking a collection ad where you can
run different products maybe with a
promotion with some nice imagery during
the holiday season so you definitely
have a plethora of options not just on
facebook but across social media for the
holidays because normally you're going
to have promotions some other things you
can do to
really maximize the holiday season for
social media and that's make
advertisements emotionally resonate with
your audience the holiday season is a
time really where you reflect on the air
you get together with friends and family
and it's religious and you know it's a
feel good in some parts of the world the
weather changes so you want to resonate
on that okay you want to resonate on
that emotion okay you always holiday
season or not you want to monitor
reports to scale successful ad campaigns
and obviously the ones that aren't
performing you want to pause okay so
with the holiday season you're likely
going to have an uptick in traffic and
uptick in eyeballs so pay attention you
don't want to spend money for money's
sake so on facebook it's a cost per
click model so you don't want to be
generating clicks without seeing any
results so go ahead and pay attention
maximize those ads that are performing
and get rid of the ones that aren't okay
and then connect the holiday with your
products or services so again think
about which ones you're going to
accentuate which ones you're going to
make more prominent during the holiday
season again thinking back to the
facebook ad types i'm thinking
carouseller collection ads if you can
really pump up some of your products and
have a nice promotion with them you can
run some nice collection ads on facebook
moving on to the next question so
somebody may ask you hey how do you make
content go viral okay i always wondered
that myself how does content go viral
it's a great question so really you're
not in necessarily in control but you
can certainly do some things to make it
more appealing for the end user to go
ahead and share it i mean that's what
going viral is right a lot of people
sharing it because the more people that
share the more people are gonna look and
find it just as enticing and they're
gonna turn around and share it so how do
you start that process really is what it
comes down to well create short form
content short form content is more
likely to go viral in other words a 10
minute video is probably not gonna
resonate with somebody something cute
funny interesting unique out of this
world in 15 30 seconds is probably going
to go viral so what does that mean make
the visual content like images and video
it works better than bodies of text so
make sure those images and video are
really compelling and then run giveaways
to draw attention and generate brand
awareness and engagement so you can
always
incentivize your users with a giveaway
or some type of promotion that's going
to maybe pique somebody's interest you
know share it with 100 friends and get
10 off as an example so these are some
of the things you can do to make it go
viral of course if you're trying to get
something to go viral you definitely
want to monitor behavior and then tweak
once you figure out how it's performing
okay you may have chosen the wrong
images you may have the wrong promotion
you may find that the contents a little
bit longer than you probably like and
you may want to cut it down some other
things you could do here is use some
trending hashtags and topics on your
post so ride that wave if you will for
any surfers in the audience hey two
people can ride the same wave so if you
got a trending hashtag use that hashtag
with that video or post you can always
ask users to interact okay so you can
always ask them to like or share
especially if they're your audience
because when somebody actually shares it
that means they're sharing it with
somebody else who also has an audience
so that's a quick way to get the ball
going so to speak about bouncing okay so
next question which industries perform
better with different platforms great
question there's a lot of different
social media platforms you got your most
popular ones all the way down to your
least popular ones i mean let's face it
social media platforms are also
geographic so some social media
platforms are more popular in say the
united states than say india russia and
vice versa we know china has a lot of
different social media platforms that
most americans in the united states
don't even use so you got to keep that
in mind but we're not talking about
geography we're talking about industry
so you got to also think about industry
here so
generally facebook it's usually food and
beverage news and media e-commerce those
are the types of industries that you
might tend to see on facebook when we
talk about e-commerce you know it could
be clothing it could be you know
restaurant okay selling or it could be a
a food company selling you know foods
and beverages you also have instagram so
instagram tends to be more beauty food
and beverage e-commerce so when we talk
about beauty we're talking about clothes
we're talking about makeup you know
maybe shoes dresses unique styles i see
a lot of that on instagram and then
linkedin for example generally works
with you know for me i look at linkedin
as b2b okay so anything you know
interesting in a specific industry
you're probably gonna see some news
items and updates on that tips and best
practices and of course jobs a lot of
recruiters on linkedin so linkedin's a
good place for you to really put
yourself out there to find that job you
seek that social media manager job okay
so here's a breakdown if you will of the
top five again in the united states you
know for those users who are watching
this from another country you know you
may find i'll be interested if you could
get some feedback here you know in the
comments section of the video go ahead
and put you know the social media
platform you use in your country and
generally what do you see on that
platform do you see food and beverage do
you see gaming or entertainment do you
see e-commerce so
share your thoughts and knowledge with
the rest of us so next question how
would you measure social media marketing
success of an organization and this is a
likely question a question you're likely
going to get okay how do you measure
success and that's across the board not
just social but ppc email marketing
display
affiliate so really you're always going
to have the right answer if you talk and
think about conversion so with
conversions about tracking content
downloads or sales or registrations or
legion or form submissions anything
where you're going to get something in
return okay so to me that's the general
answer here you know how do we measure
success well it always depends on
strategy but if you're trying to get a
sale from instagram based on your beauty
product or you got a promotion you're
running on facebook and you're running a
lead form type ad okay are you getting
people to enter in that enter in details
on the form submission do you always
want to track conversions from that
perspective okay you also have
engagement okay so your strategy may not
be conversion maybe your strategy is
simply brand awareness and engagement
you want to know how many people
participate in the conversation for
example you may post something that's
really you know hot trends it's trending
it's it's political it could be business
it could be a world of fair you want to
be able to measure how many people react
how many people comment reply repost
retweet share like etc so
engagement metrics vary across different
social media platforms but basically
when it comes to engagement you can
measure it just has to align with the
right strategy you also have awareness
again if you're just simply in it for
brand awareness okay it's all about how
many people are actually looking at it
the total volume of people okay and how
widely your message is spreading okay
what's the reach it could also be just
simply traffic to your website so you
can certainly track traffic to your
websites by clicks or shares so it
doesn't always have to be about
conversion or engagement it can simply
hey we want to drive traffic to the
website it's at 37 what are some things
to focus on when advertising on twitter
okay you can advertise on twitter
whether you knew that or not now you
know twitter is a platform where you can
pay for advertising so
what do you want to focus on when you do
advertise on twitter well you want to
emphasize urgency to make sure users
take immediate action you want to
express discounts and percentages why
well because you're limited in what you
can say on twitter you want to avoid
using hashtags that don't pertain to
your brand and product i know that may
sound like common sense but remember
you're advertising in here so you got to
be really really really careful because
you're paying you're paying for somebody
to either look at that ad or click on
that ad so some other things you want to
keep focus on is your ad copy it's got
to be short and to the point and then
make sure your ads are mobile friendly
again just like most social media
platforms twitter is no different people
are looking at twitter on their mobile
phones so video ads should have
subtitles images in the proper ratio so
you always want to thank mobile mobile
mobile mobile because most people are
using mobile on their mobile phones
whether that be in the browser or via an
app okay next question how can you use
social media to promote your event okay
so you got an event coming up i want to
promote it so you're going to turn to
social media and the first thing you do
is have affiliates fans and attendees
share resources about the event okay use
leverage your community in other words
okay you can remarket the event to
potential attendees using facebook ads
so you can do remarketing and
remarketing is basically hey somebody
who's seen it or been there or done that
you're retargeting those people you can
use photos of attendees and social
updates so depending on the event you
can have some really high profile
attendees speaking at the event or just
attending the event so use photos to
drive excitement about the event okay
you can create a uniform hashtag that
can be shared across multiple channels
you can mention the event all social
media bios so don't just limit it to one
you know cross promote it on twitter
linkedin etc and what you could do is if
you've run other events in the past
create a highlight rail from prior
events you know show people hey your
events are the events you must attend
they're the go-to events because they're
popular they're successful good
attendees usually good attendance and
then some other things you could do here
share behind the screens visual content
and again you could share pictures of
guest speakers along with their quotes
okay so you want to do everything
possible at your at your disposal
especially on social media to really
pump up the event next question how can
you perform a b testing on your ads so
for those of you that listen intently on
the email marketing part remember e a b
testing is key with email marketing what
are we testing in email we're testing
subject lines we're testing layout we're
testing call to action so the same thing
here on social media you want to do
continuous a b testing to figure out
what works and doesn't work it's very
simple the great thing about facebook is
they got an a b test feature built in so
you can certainly test different ads
great thing about facebook i like is
that you can simply start out with an
app by running an a b test you could
simply test the imagery it could be a
male versus a female you could test the
call to action a lot of things you could
test so things you can change are again
color of the elements you could change
the positioning you could change the
audience you're targeting the call to
action i mean everything everything
because the whole point is you want to
see which one works which one doesn't
work so testing can be done initially on
broader elements and then smaller finer
details like statements in your ad copy
so you could start out big just by
testing the imagery and so the female
tends to work better than male then you
know what works in terms of imagery well
take the next step and start honing it
on say the message and then once you
figure out what message works then you
can move to the next element like cta
some interesting questions you may get
include what are some things to focus on
when setting up your ad creative this
goes back almost to the a b testing you
want to use ad creative that's attention
grabbing and relevant for your business
so use a primary but bold color scheme
so you also want to you stay away from
clip art okay so again align your
imagery really is important on social
media don't use some basic cheap clipart
you don't necessarily always have to use
stock imagery either i mean it could be
imagery you took that's very relevant
and unique to your product but if you do
that don't use low resolution pixelated
images use images that are well lit so
decide on the aesthetic you want for
your creative clean and minimal or
colorful and vibrant it really depends
on you know the advertisement what it is
you're trying to promote so some other
things to focus on here to create
attention grabbing ads show images of
people benefiting from your product and
coca-cola has done this forever when
have you never seen a coca-cola
commercial with somebody with a smile on
your face drinking a bottle of coke i
don't think i've ever seen an
advertisement so when it comes to food
you should always have somebody in there
enjoying the food if it comes to clothes
should have somebody looking like they
really enjoy wearing these clothes and
they look great in them you want to
accentuate that with you know some nice
coloring sticking with your brand
guidelines okay so imagery really is
important here so you do need to make
sure the ad works for your brand without
requiring explanatory copy the image
should basically speak for itself okay
so let's finish up with content
marketing content marketing another big
digital marketing channel a lot of work
out there so
if you're going in for an interview
let's review some of the questions you
may get asked okay so starting out what
are the essential components of a good
web content okay so essential components
okay so what do we want our content to
do well we want it to be useful so web
content should be written in a way which
caters to what the reader wants okay so
somebody's not going to read your
content if it's not useful for them okay
this because it affects reader
engagement okay so if it's not
interesting it's not useful somebody's
just not going to read it plain and
simple it also has to be engaging so
listen even if it is relevant to a user
you still have to write the content so
it's engaging so you want to add
elements like imagery videos hey you can
even turn your content into an
infographic okay you want to do
something that's going to be engaging
for the user if it's engaging they're
going to read it and engage with the
content okay and then good content
should have some call to action so
content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know i've
seen a lot of blog posts just simply
start and with good content but it
doesn't leave the user with anywhere to
go so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after you're done
engaging with the good content you write
okay so some other things to think about
some other components for good content
well credibility so you know anybody can
write but are you writing about
something you know what you're writing
about are you a good talking point a
good expert or have experience about
this content so you also want to use you
know information from a legitimate
source okay so you don't want to grab
something in your and use it in your
content that's just not legitimate
because it does hurt your credibility
and the organization's credibility and
then also originality i mean write
something
that nobody else has written so
obviously you don't want to plagiarize
because if you plagiarize and there are
tools out there where people can easily
just put their content in there to see
what else is out there see if somebody
else has plagiarized it so it's very
easy to find people who plagiarize so
don't be that person what i would
recommend create a good content calendar
and come up with some ideas before you
write them next question related to
content marketing so what are the types
of content you can create well there are
a lot of things you can create start
with the blog blog to me is always a
great place to start it's a blank canvas
for your ideas your thoughts your
opinions okay that's a great thing about
a blog it accentuates personality you
can create a video videos are always
engaging you can create an infographic
infographics to me are you know hidden
gem instead of somebody reading the same
old same old you're laying this out in a
very visual way that's easy to
understand create a case study okay so
if you're a digital marketing expert
you've done social media for another
client you know write about it you know
show the successes show that you are an
expert show that you've created
successful campaigns and social and in
the form of case study you can create a
white paper white papers are good
educational pieces you can also create
an ebook okay ebook hey if you have a
lot of content you want to lay it out
and ebook's a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to content a lot of choices okay so what
are the advantages of having a content
counter so i alluded to that just a
couple of seconds ago so let's really
break this down here because content
counters to me are so important well
first of all calendar part of content
calendar allows you to think about dates
so
if you're planning something you're
going to have important dates in mind
okay so content calendar it almost
ensures you don't miss anything you know
that's a good opportunity for you to
leverage like you know black friday
cyber monday you know it's probably
important you know when those days are
if you're in e-commerce so that's why
having a content calendar helps it helps
you plan out your content based on
important dates or based on dates that
work for what you're trying to do they
also help because you could stick to a
consistent schedule okay so if you don't
have a content calendar you're probably
just arbitrarily writing content here
and there well what if your users crave
and really engage with the content
they're going to want more sticking to
something consistent is going to really
get people come back for more they know
when you're going to post they're going
to be waiting for it and if it's every
tuesday morning eight o'clock hey post
it tuesday morning eight o'clock your
users will get used to that schedule and
it does help build up your following it
does help to help build up your
community and in the end cultivates a
long-lasting relationship and then
having a content calendar also allows
you to mix up your content okay so you
can see and plan ahead different types
of content in different formats that way
it allows you to mix it up whether it be
a blog post uh an infographic a video
about different topics okay some other
advantages here saving time it just
allows you to prepare for the future
when you can prepare your efficient and
when you're efficient you're not wasting
time and so to me having a content
calendar is a must because a lot of us
are busy who has time especially if
you're going to work in a new company
let's say writing content you definitely
want to have a content counter because
you're going to want to use that time to
efficiently plan this is a new company
you're going to start working at you
want to understand who this company is
what they've done in the past what you
haven't done and what you want to do
okay so all of that helps you plan and
prepare and it saves you the time and
effort and hassle down the road and then
at the end of the day you want to be
able to figure out what works so
planning your post puts less strain on
you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or the topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh again
you're going to be on a consistent
schedule and you're not going to be
writing about the same things over and
over again so it could be just simply
twitter if you're putting a content
calendar in it together for twitter well
you don't want to have the same tweets
every other day so it does ensure that
you're getting tweets out there that are
fresh that are new that are different
and again figure out what works a
content counter makes it easier to
measure results and optimize performance
so you always want to you know maybe put
some metrics in with your content
calendar so you can see side by side
content historically that is performed
content that is not performed okay so
next question you may get what type of
content works in each stage of the
customer life cycle so you have
awareness engagement purchase
post-purchase advocacy okay so let's
break these down here so awareness okay
so you want people to understand who you
are okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping yell it could be a
cold email a video that can potentially
go viral a social media post introducing
a product you have engagement so you
want people to engage with your content
what are you going to do to get people
to engage well you could certainly write
an email and have people open that email
and go to your website you can have an
ebook where people can actually download
and read it or you can have a blog where
people can comment or landing page where
they can fill out a form submission you
have evaluation so with social media we
know there's a lot of engagement going
on but when you're putting content out
there you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case studies a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you've worked in a for a
specific product in the past and it's
worked you certainly want to put that
out there for potential clients in that
same industry purchase trying to get
people to purchase what are you gonna do
well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know website a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
okay onboarding emails get those emails
out there and get people to go back to
the website and purchase of course you
can have product and service details as
well meaning you know one one page
downloadable pdfs that describe the
product okay a post purchase okay so
people who've already purchased you
could certainly send out follow-up
emails and you can do blog round-ups you
know give people an opportunity to see
what features or updates are happening
to the product okay of course case
studies of repeat customers or content
types that detail a new feature or
service okay so if somebody's already
purchased and you may want to send them
some content of another product that
complements the product they bought so a
lot of things you can do to engage with
your user who's already purchased and
then advocacy you want people to help
you out here so have the user generate
the content you can have exclusive
discounts for your community they're
going to be your advocates so give them
exclusive discounts and then pictures of
customers engaging with your products
okay who's not gonna share that so
you're gonna have people share that
information in other words you can
generate content where hey people can
help you out here and be your advocate
okay so how do you decide what topic and
subject to write on okay well going back
to the content counter that always helps
you to see what you put in that content
calendar but there are some other
methods you can use and you could
certainly identify your target audience
and not only identify your target
audience but what their needs are okay
so you can write content based on
audience you could certainly do some
research with keywords okay what's
trending what keywords are not trending
okay and right around what's trending
for example okay you could certainly
take a look at social media for example
cora i always look at korra core is
interesting entertaining informational
hey people are certainly having
conversations on core and you can
certainly analyze those conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do i want to write a
topic around something that really just
won't go away in terms of conversing
core is a good example of analyzing
conversations they tend to be a little
bit more in depth so some other things
you could do
you can look at your competitors and
what kind of conversations are happening
on your competitors blogs or your
competitors social media platforms and
pages you can keep track of blogs and
articles from subject matter experts
commentators critics and so on okay so
you can get ideas from them another
question you may get which is very
important if you're going to start
working for a company you need to
understand the tone the tone of your
content because that is going to fit and
be in line with the company you're
working for okay so you're always going
to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand are the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience is okay and how the brand wants
to be seen by that audience so you know
if you have an older audience you're not
going to use younger audience ie street
lingo or today's lingo and and the
younger generation
you're going to use you know language
that's going to fit the audience you're
talking to and then of course the
channel itself so the content you create
must be irrespective of the channel and
consistent with brand attributes okay so
you gotta pick and choose the channel if
it's linkedin for example hey you know
linkedin is more business oriented okay
so you're not gonna be
you know as humorous as you would be say
on instagram or facebook all of these
have one thing in common again that's
brand guidelines you have to stay within
the brand what is the brand's
personality how do we want to talk to
our audience and what platform are we
using to talk to our audience how do you
promote your content once it's live well
that's always a good question hey you
doing the the work the putting in the
hard work to create this you know it
could be a video and videos take a long
time it could be an infographic an ebook
okay so send it out via email okay if
you have an email list send it out and
let people know this content's there put
a link in the email or even a piece or
snippet or preview of the content in the
email so you're using the email to
broadcast and encourage people to you
know if it's an ebook get the rest of
the ebook okay you could certainly
leverage social media to engage with
your community that's the best you know
just as good as email get out there and
let people know hey i got i got my book
published come and download it you know
you can give a discount to the first 100
people that download it okay you can
always promote your content via ads so
whether that be google or facebook you
always have an opportunity to meet more
prominent by advertising the content
that you have to offer so you can always
reach out on social media again
targeting interesting people directly so
you can always interact with people on
social or you can write for others
attract people from the web to important
pages of your website by guest posting
so you can always go on to a popular
blog post and write something and you
know link it up or or have it be
relevant to the content you've written
so next question how can you determine
how well your content is doing okay very
important again you've done all the work
you put the content calendar together
you got the content ready to go it's
published you're promoting it social
email guest blogging but you want to
determine how it's doing well depends on
the channel really is what it comes down
to so if it's organic search you want to
be able to see if it's ranking for the
keywords you optimize that content for
if it's social you want to be able to
see if you have engagement shares
comments etc of course you can always
look at analytics and see how much
traffic that blog post is getting or
that page with the white paper is
getting okay so you can always look at
your analytics and look at the traffic
okay and again you can always look to
see if there are conversions in the form
of an inquiry or lead or sale so at the
end of the day you want to align the
content with the channel and you want to
align the kpi with the content and
channel okay so if it's social you're
not likely going to get conversions
unless you're doing paid ads if you're
posting organically on social then
you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with the content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what i was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes you need to
define buyer personas to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so you're always writing for an
audience and you're going to market that
content for that audience so you always
got to keep that in mind okay run
content audits audits to determine the
best type of content that can be used in
other words how did it perform what kind
of engagement did you get with the
infographic or did that video really
really perform well or do we want to use
you know a blog post next time around or
an image next time around so continuing
on here you want to choose an
appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it wordpress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you you
come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to
choose the format and then of course you
want to publish and manage your content
after it's all said and done so these
are the steps involved again just
quickly decide on the goal the kpi
deciding your audience look at what's
worked and not worked in the past get
your content set up in the platform okay
or get the platform ready to go i should
say okay generate ideas with that
content counter i ideally go to the
content calendar for the ideas choose
that type and then publish and manage
and when i say manage i mean again going
back to analytics or going back to the
kpi that you align with that content to
see if it's performing or not okay so
next question here how do you target the
right audience for your content it's a
very good question you're not writing
content for everyone let's be honest
here so you have to collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website based on who
subscribed to your emails based on who's
following you on social media so in
other words you have people interacting
with you okay in different channels and
you need to understand who these people
are so or do they fit a certain age
range or generation are they skewed more
female to male education level what's
their affinity or interest okay do they
have a certain income so you need to
really break down your audience here and
you could do that in analytics you could
do that on social you can do that just
by looking at your email list okay the
all those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is okay so good luck to
you whether you're at interviewing for
content marketing social email
pay-per-click seo
you're gonna have a plethora of
questions being asked to you hopefully
these questions are well suited for your
interview if you guys were asked any
questions that weren't brought up in
this video then feel free to comment
below i'd love to see what other
questions are being asked in digital
marketing interviews of course if you
have any questions feel free to visit us
at simplylearn.com i want to thank you
for hanging in there and good luck and
we'll see on the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here